Nice!
So Leute, ich bin zur Abwechslung auch mal wieder, da ist schon ein paar Tage her.
Letztes Mal war ich am Sonntag, glaube ich, am Stand.
Und ich wollte auch am Sonntagabend nochmal streamen, aber irgendwie hat sich nicht ergeben, weil es in-game so gesackt hat.
Aber heute basteln wir mal ein bisschen weiter.
Ich zeige euch gleich mal was.
Ich hab ge-upgraded.
Jetzt flutscht's.
Also Twitch, ich wollte gerade sagen Steam, ich frag mich nicht, wie ich auf Steam komme.
Twitch hat es nicht so richtig mitbekommen, es sind erst vier Leute da.
Nämlich, man sieht es hier, der Serious Max, der Tempelritter und Propaganda Beef.
Oh ne, jetzt sind es schon 16.
Stonks, Stonks, geht, geht.
Richtig steil bergauf hier.
Richtig Stonks.
Habt ihr übrigens schon für mich die News des Tages gelesen, was mich wieder richtig abfackt?
Was flutscht?
Übertragungsgeschwindigkeit auf die SSD.
Nachricht des Tages, die mich richtig abfackt, als ich das gelesen hat.
Hier.
Microsoft bringt Kontopflicht für Pro Edition.
Also sprich, die testen gerade in Windows-Insider-Bills, ob man nicht eine Microsoft-Account-Zwang machen kann, der aber nicht...
Den gibt's ja im Prinzip jetzt schon, aber du kannst jetzt um zwei Ecken klicken und es ist weg.
Und die testen jetzt, ob man wirklich für eine loka-
Jetzt muss man sich mal wirklich auf der Zunge zergehen lassen.
Für eine lokale Windows-Installation, die nichts mit Cloud oder sonst was zu tun hat,
ich zwingend ein Microsoft-Account brauche.
Dazu kann ich wirklich bloß sagen...
Oh Gott!
Oh Gott, bitte nicht!
Nein!
So, und das testen die jetzt in der Insider-Bill.
Also sprich, im normalen Windows 11 ist das nicht drin.
Aber wir kennen ja Microsoft.
Also, wenn das jetzt nicht instant den riesen Shitstorm gibt, dann kommt das wahrscheinlich demnächst auch in Windows 11 und wahrscheinlich auch in Windows 10.
Ich meine, Microsoft versuchte seit Jahren schon und die Leute wollen den Scheiß nicht.
Und die denken sich, ha, jetzt muss man die Leute halt zu ihrem Glück zwingen.
Mag ja alles sein.
Ich habe heute auch schon wieder in irgendeinem Forum-Thread gelesen, ja, aber ein Microsoft-Account hätte ja auch so viele Vorteile.
Meinetwegen soll mir recht sein.
Aber wenn das so geil ist und so wahnsinnig krass und viele Vorteile hätte,
dann müsste man die Leute wahrscheinlich nicht dazu zwingen, den Kram zu verwenden, oder?
Also, die Logik hat sich mir nicht erschlossen.
Richtig...
Pegalogik.
Ja, natürlich ist es so.
Vorteile für die Firma, eigenes Ökosystem auch.
Natürlich, ja, klar.
Das ist schon, glaube ich, jedem klar, was Microsoft damit will, aber es geht mir trotzdem auf den Sack.
Selbst Apple, genau, das sagt, selbst Apple hat keinen richtigen Account-Zwang.
Ich meine, die meisten Leute haben natürlich trotzdem einen Apple-Account.
Aber du kannst dein iPhone und dein Zeug auch ohne Apple-Account verwenden.
Account-Zwang ist richtig hängen geblieben.
Ja, ja, Scoreboard kommt jetzt ja irgendwann in zwei Monaten oder so.
Mir kann immer noch keiner erzählen, warum die irgendwie ein halbes Jahr brauchen, um Scoreboard zu implementieren.
Ja, ja, nee, nee, das habe ich schon richtig verstanden.
Man muss ja eben unterscheiden können zwischen einer, wie sagt man so schön, zwischen einer Erklärung und einer Rechtfertigung.
Das ist ja eine Erklärung dafür, das macht es nicht besser.
Deswegen, ich habe dich schon richtig verstanden, du findest das auch scheiße.
Du sagst halt nur, was Microsoft sich dabei denkt, da ist ja auch recht.
Microsoft denkt sich, im Prinzip, wisst ihr, was sich Microsoft denkt?
Denkt, die haben diesen Gedanken.
So, Rest sind egal.
Moin.
Microsoft und denken.
Doch, Microsoft denkt sich schon viel.
Vor allem Stonks denkt sich Microsoft.
Und Microsoft, man muss ja Microsoft auch wirklich mal zugute halten.
Die letzten Jahre über, die haben durchaus sinnvolle Sachen gemacht.
Visual Studio Code, ich hatte ja am Anfang der ganzen Java Script Editor Geschichten im Leben nicht gedacht, dass man in Java Script Editor wirklich, man quasi, wie soll ich sagen, kaum noch dran vorbei kommt, aber die haben es geschafft.
Visual Studio Code ist wirklich nice, kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Was sie mit GitHub machen, ist auch nicht verkehrt.
Auch die ganze Cloud-Geschichte, das ist alles schon teilweise, kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Das Windows ist halt Crap und Office ist immer noch Crap.
Übrigens gibt es eine lustige Story von mir auf der Arbeit zu Microsoft und PowerPoint und Geschiss.
Ich habe mal eine Präsentation gemacht.
Das ging zum irgendwie Server-Dokumentation oder sowas.
Der Inhalt war absolut unspektakulär und nicht spannend jetzt irgendwie zu erzählen, aber es ging ja eher um die Sachen drumherum.
So, und ich hasse PowerPoint.
Ihr wisst, ich persönlich verwende kein Office.
Ich verwende Office, also mein Rechner ist Office-frei.
Ich glaube, ich habe irgendeine Version von LibreOffice installiert, aber die verwende ich nicht.
Also ich verwende kein Office 365, kein Office 2019, kein Microsoft Office, kein LibreOffice.
Ich verwende keine Office-Produkte, nichts.
So, und also habe ich meine, wenn ich irgendwas präsentieren muss oder so, habe ich das früher immer so gemacht.
Ich habe ein PDF erstellt.
Ne, auch auf der Arbeit nicht.
So, ich habe einfach ein PDF erstellt, PDF im Fullscreen geöffnet und dann die Seiten durchgeklickt, easy.
So, bis zu dem einen Tag, da habe ich mal eine Präsentation gehalten.
Es ging irgendwie um Server-Dokumentation oder sowas.
Und mein Stil ist es bei Präsentation.
Ich mache das halt nicht für die 1950er-Boomer-Generation, sondern ich bin halt so ein Zwischending.
Ich bin jetzt mittlerweile zwar selber Boomer, aber noch nicht so alt.
Das heißt, ich mache Emojis rein und ich mache halt auch irgendwelche blöden Bildchen teilweise rein.
So, und das ist natürlich nicht business stonks-kompatibel, das muss einem ja klar sein.
So, und ich habe eine PDF Präsentation gemacht.
Ich habe eine PDF Präsentation gemacht, das durchgeklickt und sonst was.
Und da war ich fertig.
So, und dann ist den Leuten, also dem einen, ist nichts Besseres eingefallen, als mich zu fragen.
Das ist kein Witz.
Ich meine, eigentlich mega passiv-aggressiv, gell.
Der hat mich nach der Präsentation gefragt, kennen Sie PowerPoint?
Aber wie?
Kennen Sie keinen PowerPoint oder irgendwie sowas, hat er mich gefragt.
Da habe ich gesagt, doch, ich kenne PowerPoint, ich mag PowerPoint, aber nicht.
Und dann hat er als nächstes angefangen, ja, die Präsentation wäre ja nicht im Corporate-Design gewesen.
Da habe ich gesagt, ja, okay, und ja.
Ja, und also, ich habe dann alles gewartet, kommt da jetzt noch was?
Der hat das dann gesagt, es ist aber nicht im Corporate-Design.
Und ich habe mir so gesagt, ja, okay, also was ist jetzt der Punkt, also was soll mir das jetzt sagen?
Aber ne, zu dem Inhalt kam nichts mehr.
Er hat gesagt, kennen Sie nicht PowerPoint?
Und dann hat er erst gesagt, es ist nicht im Corporate-Design.
Man hätte wirklich sagen müssen, ich kenne PowerPoint sehr gut, deswegen benutze ich PDF.
Oh man, also ganz ehrlich, wenn die Leute zum Inhalt nichts zu sagen haben
und einfach nur, dass es nicht Corporate-Design ist und dass es nicht PowerPoint ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Seitdem mache ich es ein bisschen anders.
Seitdem mache ich es ein bisschen anders, weil es hat mich jetzt persönlich eigentlich nicht gejuckt, dass ihn das gejuckt hat.
Das Dumme ist, im Zweifelsfall hast du in irgendwelchen, doch, doch, machen wir gleich.
Im Zweifelsfall hast du dann wirklich irgendwelche Business-Boomer-Sätzen,
die sind so gedreht gehabt von Anfang an, dass es nicht Corporate-Design-Powerpoint ist,
dass sie sich den Rest gar nicht mehr richtig anhören.
Manchmal müssen die sich das anhören.
Toxy, danke für den Sub.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich irgendwelche anderen Subs übersehen habe.
Danke Leute, für alle, die gesagt haben.
Toxy, hier 24 Hyper-Subscription-Monate.
Zumindest, ich mache es jetzt ein bisschen anders.
Ich muss übrigens am Montag auch wieder was präsentieren.
Wo habe ich meine Hyper-Subscription?
Ich habe das normale Subscriber.
Hier, richtig Hyper-Subscriber, Toxy.
Und Matrix HD auch, hier nochmal Hyper-Subscriber.
Ja, ich mache es jetzt anders.
Ich mache jetzt Powerpoint auf der Arbeit, aber nur im Web.
Ich mache Office 365 über dem Browser.
Wusste ich, dass das in React programmiert ist?
Also Frontend Framework ist das.
Office 365 ist eine React-Anwendung.
Im größten Teil habe ich letztens irgendwo gelesen.
War React nicht Facebook?
Oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Also sprich Microsoft Office ist quasi mit Facebook-Technologie gebaut im Web.
Aber gut, ich meine, es gibt ja noch mehr Seiten.
Zumindest, ich muss am Montag wieder irgendwas präsentieren.
Ich mache es ja mittlerweile anders mit Präsentation.
Ich nehme Powerpoint und nehme die Firmenvorlage nur mit dem Unterschied,
dass ich jegliche Sachen aus der Firmenvorlage rauslösche.
Außer, dass es oben rechts so ein Mini...
Ich kann euch jetzt das Logo nicht zeigen.
Sonst wüsstet ihr, wo ich arbeite.
Nur, dass es oben rechts so ein Mini-Logo gibt.
Das habe ich dagelassen.
Die restlichen Sachen habe ich alles rausgeschmissen.
Und wenn sich jetzt einer sagt, das ist nicht Corporate Design,
dann sage ich, wo kommt denn dort das Logo her?
Weil ansonsten ist das Corporate Design bei uns wirklich maßlos beschissen.
Also das ist nicht nur beschissen, weil es Powerpoint ist.
Es ist auch beschissen, weil es beschissen für Powerpoint gemacht ist.
Das ist Doppel-Doppel-Crap.
Äh, die haben Probleme.
Wisst ihr, was ich am Montag präsentieren darf?
Am Montag darf ich mich unbeliebt machen, Leute.
Am Montag darf ich mich unbeliebt machen, und zwar...
Bei uns auf der Arbeit sind sie jetzt auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen.
Also aktuell hatten wir ja bisher immer...
So, ja, sagen wir mal, zumindest für die Leute
mit maximalen Berechtigungen, also aus der Administration,
aus der Ecke, wo ich ja auch mal ursprünglich gekommen bin.
Die haben, du hast mehr oder weniger eh maximale Rechte.
Ich könnte mich bei uns auf irgendwelche Live-Server verbinden
und in Datenbank Dampf ziehen und ins Darknet hochladen, im Prinzip.
Also ich habe Rechte überall.
Und da hat man gesagt, okay, die Leute haben auch spezielle Anforderungen.
Die haben freie Betriebssystemauswahl.
Also bei uns ist freie Betriebssystemauswahl
eigentlich mal gang und gäbe gewesen,
außer jetzt, sagen wir mal, für die Personalabteilung oder so was.
Die haben schon vorgefertigte Win-Haus-Kisten gekriegt.
Aber die Leute, die eh quasi maximale Rechte hatten,
da hat man sich gedacht, pff, warum sollen wir die gängeln?
Also wir hatten die ganze Zeit freie Betriebssystemauswahl.
Jetzt nicht mehr.
Wir haben keine freie Betriebssystemauswahl mehr.
Und sie hatten jetzt eine richtige Five-Hat-Idee.
Sie haben gesagt, okay, die Administrationen,
Leute, die Administrationen machen,
die brauchen ja trotzdem Administratorrechte.
Und wenn wir jetzt keine Ledungskisten mehr geben mit Freischaltung,
dann brauchen die irgendwas zum Arbeiten.
Dann sind sie auf die super schlaue Idee gekommen.
Sie haben ein VMR-Cluster aufgesetzt.
Nee, ein Zytrix-Cluster.
Zytrix, Zytrix, Zytrix, ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Cluster aufgesetzt und haben gesagt,
ihr sollt jetzt alle mit remote, privilegierten Windows-VMs arbeiten.
Und als ich das das erste Mal gehört habe, habe ich mir schon gedacht,
das funktioniert doch hinten und vorne nicht.
Und die Sache ist jetzt die, diese Sache ist irgendwie seit 1-2 Monaten da.
Und es war ja auch zu erwarten, es funktioniert nichts gescheit.
Und ich darf mich jetzt am Montag hinstellen.
Und passt mal auf, das ist die Runde auf Doom.
Ich werde die wahrscheinlich so abfacken da alle,
weil ich ihnen erzählen muss, wie kacke das ist.
Ich versuche das ja schon diplomatisch zu machen.
Also wir haben am Montag Security-Runde,
weil das ursprünglich irgendwie von Security angeleiert wurde.
Wir haben jetzt die Runde, da sind unsere Security-Leute da.
Alle Abteilungsleiter sind da, übergreifend.
Also es sind irgendwie so 12, 13 Leute oder so was am Start.
Und ich darf mich dann am Montag dahinstellen.
Ich muss mal überlegen, es ist Montag.
Ich gehe sogar freiwillig dafür eine Stunde auf die Arbeit.
Also ich gehe nicht, ich joine remote, um das vorzustellen.
So und ich muss jetzt 12 Leuten, die das absolut nicht hören wollen,
weil sie genau wissen, dass das Arbeit bedeutet
und es Sachen komplizierter machen,
muss ich am Montag erklären, warum ihre Idee kacke ist.
Wobei man ja sagen muss, dass die Idee vom Ansatz her
durchaus Teil eines Konzepts sein kann.
Ich ende meine Präsentation auch mit einer Folie Lösungsansätze,
dass es nicht gar so negativ ist.
Aber das Ding ist echt unbenutzbar.
Das pure Copy-Pasten funktioniert nicht.
Du möchtest was copy-pasten, entweder copy-pastet es nicht in der VM,
Islam ist fucked oder macht es doppelt oder so was.
Komplett für'n Arsch.
Also wenn schon copy-pastet nicht funktioniert,
muss man eigentlich gar nicht weiter erzählen, oder?
Und die Performance von irgendeiner Shit Tricks VM
glaube ich nicht drüber reden.
Du meinst, die vereinen sich darin, dass sie beide kacke sind.
Team-Viewer-Lizenzen.
Don't cry so much. 13 Monate, danke für den Sub.
Horizon? Ich hab... Ja, kann sein.
Nee, nee, nee, nicht.
Horizon ist das nicht, das mit 3D-Beschleunigung und so
und Graph-GUI-Beschleunigung und so.
Nee, nee, das ist so lahm, das kann das nicht sein.
Ja, ja, es ist lächerlich, ne?
Und dann wird immer erzählt, ah, wir sind doch super agil
und du kannst nichts Neues ausprobieren.
Also eine Sache habe ich festgestellt, nicht nur bei mir.
Also dort, wo ich arbeite, kenne ich es aus erster Hand,
aber auch, was ihr mir so öfters erzählt ist,
dass umso größer und umso Business-Enterprise-iger
dieses Unternehmen ist, umso zwiegespaltener sind die.
Und zwar auf der einen Seite haben die, ich sag mal so,
die eine Hälfte, die möchte alles so prozessorientiert,
so restriktiv, so klassisch, Boomer, Business-Enterprise-mäßig
wie nur irgendwie möglich.
Und die andere Seite möchte sich aber als modern, agil
und zukunftsweisend verkaufen.
Und das sind zwei Sachen, die funktionieren einfach nicht zusammen.
Und das sind zwei Teile innerhalb eines,
gerade bei so großen Business-Boomer-Dingern,
wo ich arbeite und ich kenne es ja auch von euch,
das ist immer so ein permanenter Kampf zwischen diesen zwei Seiten.
Copy-Paste funktioniert, ja, ja.
Prinzipiell funktioniert Copy-Paste, aber es funktioniert nicht zuverlässig.
Mal geht's, mal geht's nicht.
Mal musst du übers Extra-Menü Copy-Paste
und mal hast du, wenn du eine Taste drückst,
zwei- bis dreimal rein Copy-Paste, für den Arsch.
Hab ich.
Ich hab GIFs drinne.
Ich hab paar Sachen aufgenommen,
wenn es 20 Sekunden dauert zum Starten und so was.
Browser-Crashen zum Beispiel und so was.
So, okay Leute, ich switch mal kurz auf meinen Linux-VM.
Ich erzähle euch mal kurz, was wir machen.
Das ist eine, ich nenne es mal indirekte Fortsetzung vom letzten Stream.
Man sieht ja auch noch ein bisschen was übrig geblieben vom letzten Stream.
Ich hab mir ein HP Microserver Gen 10 Plus gekauft.
Die Version für irgendwie 700 Euro.
Das ist ein 4-Kern Xeon, 16G RAM.
Boah, glaubt das weiß, mehr oder weniger.
Der Preischamp ist offline, ja.
So ein Teil hab ich mir gekauft.
Und da haben wir das letzte Mal Unraid drauf installiert
und schon ein bisschen rumgebastelt.
Ich hatte das letzte Mal allerdings Probleme,
dass es mit meinem Cache nicht so schnell war, wie ich das gerne hätte.
Da zeige ich euch jetzt gleich mal was zu.
Jetzt flutscht der Cache nämlich.
Sieht das Programm so aus?
Was?
Nö.
Ja.
Jaja.
So sieht das aus.
Wenn ich mich einlogge, kann ich auswählen zwischenunter.
Jaja.
So sieht das aus.
Also so dieses GUI ist das.
Das hast du auch gekauft als Test-Server, nice.
Ja, das Ding ist echt nicht übel.
Ich meine, für so richtig High-IQ-Prot-Einsatz würde ich es nicht machen.
Ich meine, du hast keine Hotspot-Rahmen.
Du hast, glaubt, nur ein Netzteil und sowas.
Aber reichte dicke, ne, für daheim.
So, irgendjemand hat noch was gefragt.
Du hast so einen Tipp für mich, ich arbeite im Marketing, auch mein Bylines.
Egal.
Du hast öfters was mit der IT zu tun.
Die Jungs bei mir im Unternehmen sind einfach nicht für mich.
Die geben nen Fuck und denken nicht mit.
Tja.
Die Sache ist die.
Also.
Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, das stimmt nicht.
Aber hast du dir schon mal Gedanken drüber gemacht, dass, wenn das vielleicht die Experten
sagen, dass die besser Bescheid wissen als du.
Also vielleicht ist das, was die sagen, ja gar nicht so doof.
Ich weiß jetzt natürlich nicht, um was es geht.
Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, das stimmt nicht, was du schreibst.
Ja.
Aber vielleicht ist es ja, was die sagen, gar nicht so doof.
Weiß jetzt ja nicht, um was es geht.
Dann haben eure Atmen scheiße gebaut.
Ja, das kann schon sein.
Es ist ja nicht mein Problem.
Es funktioniert nicht richtig.
Aber wie gesagt, Grafikausgabe ist mega für den Arsch.
Du machst ein Visual Studio Code auf und nicht nur, dass es irgendwie 20 Sekunden startet.
Das verschluckt auch Fokus beim Track and Drop und sowas.
Also das ist ganz, ganz ätzend.
Ja, dafür ist es wirklich gut.
Ja, genau, also den Preis-Champ, den habe ich abgeschaltet.
Ja, der war nicht mehr aktuell.
Der Crawler war komplett outdated.
Das hat im Prinzip mehr Probleme gemacht, wahrscheinlich, als es einem hilft.
Ja, so, ich starte jetzt mal die Kiste oder gucken wir uns das zusammen an.
Erst mal die VM anschmeißen.
Du beißt dir in den Arsch nicht die Xeon-Variante gekauft haben.
Ich glaube, die normale ist auch in Ordnung.
Das ist ein Pentium G400, noch irgendwas.
Pentium, was ist denn in dem normalen drin?
Oh, keine Ahnung.
Das ist aber auch jetzt nicht so, ach nur zwei Kerne.
Ja, dann ist es räudig, dann ist es schlecht.
Laro, danke schön für den Zap. Zwei Kerne ist zu wenig, ich kann es vergessen.
Max, wenn du willst, berate ich euch.
Consulting-Künste sind sehr gut.
Hey, ich würde dich sogar empfehlen, ja.
Aber die haben schon jede Menge Leute dafür.
Ich weiß auch nicht, ob es am Know-How scheitert oder an der Teeigkeit, ja.
Aber eins muss ich sagen, also Umut, wenn du dich damit auskennst,
also was, also eine der Hauptprobleme, die ich mit der VM habe,
ist erstens Input-Lag, Output-Lag, also UI-Lag,
gerade wenn man es im Browser verwendet,
aber auch wenn man diesen Zytrix-Client installiert, ist auch nicht besser.
Aber Input-Lag auf Doom, halbe Sekunde für Tastenanschläge und sowas.
Copy-Paste, was teilweise nicht richtig funktioniert.
Also mit Native-Speed nicht ansatzweise zu vergleichen.
Damit kann vielleicht die Personalabteilungsfrau in Excel ein bisschen was machen,
aber ich kann damit keine Kisten verwalten und neue Sachen entwickeln.
Adam, wieso ich Minecraft Windows 11 nicht installieren kann?
Moment, hast du nicht eben auch gerade gefragt, dass deine Jungs in der IT keine Ahnung haben?
Das ist doch cheap bait, oder? Das ist doch alles cheap bait.
Gib's zu, Timo, das ist...
Das ist cheap bait alles.
Oder sind deswegen die IT-Jungs bei dir unfähig,
weil die nicht wissen, wie man Minecraft richtig installiert?
Der Balken bei der Installation bewegt sich nicht.
Vielleicht Windows-Viren-Scanner, was auch immer.
Das ist eine gute Frage, ja, ich glaube, der kann ECC rammen, genau.
Aber anbuffert und der wird auch mit 16G ECC, glaube ich, ausgeliefert schon.
Na, da bin ich ja froh. So, okay, ich zeige euch jetzt mal was.
Also, das ist noch vom letzten Mal. Habt ihr gesehen?
So, aber hier sieht man es noch vom letzten Mal.
Also, merkt euch das mal, mein Cache, das letzte Mal im Android,
mein Cache war 700 MB, es sind nicht MB, es sind maybe,
ach du Scheiße, was sind das, maybe, maybe, maybe, maybe, maybe bait, oder maybe?
Nee, maybe, es ist maybe bait, maybe bait.
Nein, nein, es ist maybe, es ist nicht maybe, es ist maybe.
Das kann sich auch kein Mensch merken.
Also, es sind 710 MIB Sekunden, also maybe bait die Sekunde.
So, und jetzt starte ich die Kiste mal, es dauert kurz.
Erst mal booten. Und dann zeige ich euch mal, wie schnell mein Cache jetzt cached.
Nein, es war ja nur ein bisschen hier lokal, das ist nicht, das ist nicht auf Shit.
Nee, ist es nicht. Aber wir haben mehr oder weniger alles im Stream gemacht.
Also, ich habe nichts davon aufs Stream gemacht. So, Kiste booted.
Was hat das Ding überhaupt von der IP? Ich glaube, 1, 2, 1, 2, 2, 1, 4, 8 hat es glaube ich.
Gucken wir mal, ob das Ding gleich da ist.
Und dann zeige ich euch jetzt mal High Speed, Bam, Bam, Bam, Cache.
Und dann erzähle ich euch, wie ich das gemacht habe.
Und das wäre nicht möglich gewesen, Leute, ohne den, wo ist das E-Mode?
Das wäre nicht ohne den Chat möglich gewesen.
Hätte nicht funktioniert, ihr werdet auch gleich sehen, warum.
Chat war einfach wieder way too high IQ.
Weißt du, ob ihr die Standard Variante habt oder schon die End... ich habe keine Ahnung.
Max gibt es eine gute Variante, die es auch für die
E-Mode gibt, die man in Piesen richtig einrückt.
Ja, die einfachste Erklärung ist, du rückst einheitlich ein, weil sonst funktioniert es nicht.
Ob du jetzt 2 Spaces, Tab oder 4 Spaces machst, ist, würde ich mal sagen, persönliche Präferenz.
Oder halt je nachdem, wenn du mit mehreren Leuten programmierst, dass man sich auf was einigt.
Wichtig ist nur, einheitlich einzurücken und genauso wie Yammel.
Yammel ist auch wichtig einheitlich einzurücken, sonst funktioniert es nicht.
Ok, die Kiste ist da.
Oh, Bad Request, warum?
Monkaz! Achso, HTTPS, kommt besser.
Normalerweise macht der immer automatisch HTTPS.
Dies ist der dumm alter Lan.
So, also, jetzt monte ich den Kempel mal.
Also ihr seht mittlerweile, was ich drin hab, ist... ist das mein Dark Reader?
Mein Dark Reader macht komisches Zeug.
Jaja, also was ich drin hab, ist folgendes aktuell.
Ich hab 2x 10TB, also das sind alles Sachen, die hatte ich noch da.
Bis auf das, was ich euch jetzt gleich zeige.
Also ich hab drin 2x 10TB, 1x 10TB Parity, eine Samsung SSD 79 Evo, 2TB als Cache.
Wer aufgepasst hat das letzte Mal, wird feststellen, es ist keine USB-Cache-Festplatte mehr.
Keine USB-Cache-Sahndisk mehr.
Und jetzt werd ich das Ganze mal starten.
Oh, ich brauch ein Passwort.
Ist das? Ja, das ist hidden.
Kann ich einen Tippen starten?
Don't save.
So, 2TB Cache, klar, muss sein.
Prager.
Nice, funktioniert.
Okay, ich lock mich mal kurz drauf ein.
SSH root add.
Jaja, yes.
Also, passt mal auf.
Das letzte Mal habt ihr es ja gerade gesehen.
Ungefähr 700 bis 750 MB.
Ich sag MB.
Ich scheiß mal auf MB-Byte.
MB, okay?
Gleiche Einheit wie jetzt auch.
Vom Cache, und jetzt passt mal auf.
MNT, Cache.
Machen wir mal hier wieder, was weiß ich.
PPV nach image oder blub.image aus DevZero.
Und passt mal auf, wie das jetzt flutscht.
Obacht, obacht.
Seht ihr das?
Es geht ein bisschen runter gleich.
Aber es bleibt deutlich schneller.
Oh, es flutscht, hä?
So.
Und wisst ihr auch, woran das liegt?
Dass es jetzt so schnell ist.
Weil es keine USB-S-Systeme ist.
Sondern eine richtig über NVMe angebundene EVO Plus 2 TB.
Äh, wie ging das nochmal?
NVMe?
Äh, du Scheiße.
NVMe Show Smart.
Wie ging das nochmal?
Ja, der Thomas Crenn, der weiß wieder Bescheid.
NVMe.
Hier, das da.
Nein, nein, nein.
NVMe Smart.
Wie ging das denn jetzt nochmal?
Es war NVMe Dev, äh, NVMe Null oder so.
Und jetzt muss ich was machen?
Show Smart oder sowas?
Ja.
Das, ja.
Show.
Blöd, wo ist das? Hä?
Wie ging das nochmal?
Smart.
Smart Lock.
So.
Und ihr werdet feststellen, es ist direkt per NVMe erkannt.
Und, ähm, er ist gar nicht so warm.
Er ist eigentlich relativ gut im grünen Bereich.
Und ihr seht, die Geschwindigkeit ist doppelt so schnell wie das letzte Mal.
Vorher hatten wir 700 noch was.
Und jetzt haben wir, ähm, 2 GB, GB Byte oder was auch immer pro Sekunde.
Also wir sind ungefähr doppelt bis 2,5-fach schneller.
So, und wie ich das gemacht habe, ist Folgendes.
Hat ein bisschen Geld gekostet.
Ähm,
ich hab mir eine PC-Express-Karte gekauft.
Ach so, vielleicht muss ich jetzt noch erzählen, was man sonst nicht sieht.
IP Link.
Ähm, das ist nach wie vor ein 10 GB Anschluss hier dran.
Ach so, nee, warte mal.
ETH Tool, ETH Tool, ETH Null.
Nee.
Hä? Hat ETH Tool nicht angezeigt, wie das gesyncht ist sonst?
Ach hier.
Ähm,
Advertised Link-Modes.
Ja, wo ist denn hier Link-Mode?
Hier, Speed, also es ist 10 GB.
So.
Excellent.
Hättest du nicht Link-Aggregation machen können,
über vier,
die vier Netzwerk-Ports?
Doch, das hätte man theoretisch auch machen können.
Man hätte aber auch eine 2,5 oder 5 GB USB-Adapter anschließen können.
Also es gibt verschiedene Varianten.
Nee, aber ich hab mit gestern mit Hetzer, äh,
nee, nee, noch ein bisschen mich ausgetauscht.
Ähm,
die sind immer noch interessiert dran, dass wir dieses Jahr auch was machen,
aber wir müssen uns erst mal was überlegen.
So.
Der Chat war nämlich richtig high IQ.
Wisst ihr, was ich mir gekauft hab?
Ich hab mir sowas hier gekauft.
Das Ding hab ich mir gekauft.
Das ist eigentlich eine Erweiterungskarte für QNAP-Geräte
mit einem PCI-Express-Switch,
einem 10-Gigabit-Anschluss
und Slots für zwei onboard NVMe-SSDs.
Plus Kühlpads und einem ordentlichen Kupferkühler mit Lüfter.
Ich weiß nicht, wer mir das empfohlen hat letztes Mal im Chat.
Irgendjemand hat letztes Mal im Chat gemeint,
er hat sich auch sowas gekauft und das passt rein, das ist richtig gut.
So, das Problem war nur, das Ganze zu finden.
Doch, das hat ziemlich genau 200 Euro gekostet.
So, das Problem ist nur, findet das mal.
Versucht mal, das Ding zu kaufen.
So einfach ist das nicht.
Guckt mal bei Geizhals.
Da nutzt man übrigens mal PCI-Express-Bandbreite.
Ja, PCI-Express-Gen3 ist eh schon richtig, flutscht richtig.
Nee, das ist das Alte.
Da darf man sich übrigens nicht chibaden lassen.
Also, lasst euch nicht chibaden.
Das ist die Alte.
Das ist die Alte mit PCI-Express 2.0.
Das ist viel zu langsam für NVMe und Cengage.
Ihr braucht unbedingt PCI-Express 3.0.
Das ist die Neue, das ist die Alte, die suckt.
Und hier gibt's...
Ihr findet mal nix.
So, wisst ihr, wo ich die gefunden hab?
In Frankreich.
Bei LDLC.
Die kennt ihr wahrscheinlich aus Counter-Strike.
Zumindest kannte ich die bisher nur aus Counter-Strike.
Dann hab ich gelernt, dass es mit der größten Hardware-Versand in Frankreich ist.
Und die haben was zum Liefern.
Die haben die Dinger.
Also hab ich mir aus Frankreich das Teilen bestellt.
Und am Ende hab ich irgendwie 200 Euro bezahlt.
Ging ausgesprochen schnell, hätt ich nicht gedacht.
GG Eats.
Und funktioniert wunderbar.
So, und das Ding hab ich jetzt drinne.
Und jetzt haben wir einfach mal auf den Cache 2 GB die Sekunde.
Bam.
Ach so, um euch zu zeigen, wie heiß das wird.
Gucken wir mal schnell.
Ich hätt mir meinen PV mal kopieren sollen.
Ich hab keinen Bock, das nochmal zu schreiben.
So, ich zeig euch jetzt mal, wie heiß das Ganze wird.
So, ah nein, nein, nein, da will ich...
Das ist der USB-Stick.
Auf den USB-Stick will ich garantiert nix kopieren.
Mount Cache.
So, speichern wir hier mal hier.
NVMe.
Was war das?
Smart Lock.
Def NVMe 0.
So, und schaut mal.
Die Temperaturen halten sich im grünen Bereich.
Das wird zwar ein bisschen wärmer.
Und wenn es irgendwie so mal bei 70 Grad ist, dann springt der Lüfter an.
Aber dann bleibt es dann da auch stehen.
Aber 2 GB die Sekunde ist schon sehr Giga-Chat.
Grafikkarten liefern sie leider nicht nach Deutschland.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ach ja, mein Cache, das kommt ja noch dabei.
Was ihr auch wissen müsst, wahrscheinlich wäre es normalerweise noch minimal schneller.
Weil mein Cache ist ja auch komplett encrypted.
Also, der muss noch komplett alles verschlüsseln.
Also, er muss gerade alle Nullen, die ich drauf schreibe, verschlüsseln.
Nee, Watch sagt, die coolen Leute spammen das Command.
Warum Cache encrypten?
Naja, weil auf dem Cache beispielsweise die Daten der ganzen Docker-Container und VMs liegen.
Also, wenn du zum Beispiel eine VM machst mit Heimautomatisierung und sonst was
und hast da Tokens und Passwörter drin,
dann würde ich die nicht auf einem unverschlüsselten Cache liegen lassen.
Können die SSDs normal an Speicher verwenden?
Jaja, kannst du.
Du kannst sagen, dass der bei Datenübertragung cached auf die SSDs,
aber du kannst auch sagen, dass da standardmäßig, das ist auch klar, glaube ich, Default,
dass der standardmäßig VMs und Docker-Container und so Sachen nur auf die SSD macht.
Was ist da für ein Setup?
Nein, das ist kein ZFS.
Du kannst ZFS machen mit bisschen manuellem Gebasteln oder mit Addons kannst du ZFS machen.
Ich habe ganz normal XFS drauf, encrypted XFS.
Und Unraid macht das ziemlich, wie soll ich sagen, ziemlich banal eigentlich.
Die mappen einfach alles übereinander, also zum Beispiel hier Mount User.
So, dieses Mount User ist eigentlich nur, ich weiß nicht, ob man den Mount sieht.
Mount Cap User, was auch immer SHFS sein soll, keine Ahnung.
Das ist irgendein Overlay Mount, wo die einfach alle Platten und die SSD
zu einem virtuellen gemeinsamen Ordner machen.
Unten drunter sind das unabhängige Disks.
Das ist so ziemlich die einfachste Variante, wie man das machen kann.
Dann braucht man kein Raid für und nichts.
Und wenn man einstellt, dass man die SSD als Cache für Datenübertragung verwenden will,
dann geht erstmal alles auf die SSD und in einem gewissen Intervall läuft dann im Hintergrund was,
was die Sachen noch zusätzlich auf die Festplatten schiebt.
Also das ist tatsächlich vom Ansatz her äußerst simpel
und ich denke auch mal dementsprechend recht fehlerunanfällig.
Gucken wir uns das Ganze mal an, jetzt wird es ein bisschen wärmer.
Wahrscheinlich hat es deswegen auch gedrosselt.
Aber es ist immer noch ziemlich genau doppelt so schnell wie die USB SSD.
Richtig nice.
So, und was wir heute machen ist Folgendes, müssen wir ein bisschen ausprobieren.
Ich will mal ein paar Addons installieren.
Ich will zum Beispiel Let's Encrypt Zertifikate machen und sowas.
Wie man prinzipiell Let's Encrypt Zertifikate macht, weiß ich, weil,
denn das ist das alte, ich mache mal kurz hier alles zu.
Jaja, root.
So, wie man prinzipiell Addons installiert und so weiß ich, habe ich ja auch hier schon ein paar gemacht.
Und ihr seht ja, ich habe sogar ein gültiges Let's Encrypt Zertifikat.
Also ich habe auch schon geguckt, wie man da Zertifikate drauf kopieren kann.
Ist an sich relativ simpel.
Ich will das aber automatisiert haben und ich will
Zertifikate für alle meine Docker Container und VMs.
Das müssen wir mal gucken, wie wir das jetzt am besten einrichten.
Und vorher machen wir mal ein bisschen Geschwindigkeitstest.
Ich will nämlich mal kurz wissen, wie schnell der Kram jetzt eigentlich wirklich ist.
Was ist eine SSD?
Hä, was mein ich? Langsam.
Was für eine SSD hast du jetzt benutzt?
Eine Samsung Evo 720, ne, eine Samsung 970.
970 Evo, nicht 720, 970 Evo.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Markbrech, danke für den Sub.
Sorry Leute, wenn ich wieder irgendjemanden übersehen habe.
Kannst du erklären, was und wofür Zertifikate für VMs und Docker Container sind?
Naja, im Prinzip einfach nur, dass es besser aussieht und dass die hier oben
ein Symbol hat, das alles ordnungsgemäß ein echtes Zertifikat hat.
Das brauchst du nicht wirklich.
Also das ist eigentlich, wenn du das nur intern verwendest und nur du drauf zugreifst,
kannst du ohne Probleme selbstseit-automatisch generierte Zertifikate nehmen.
Das brauchst du keine gültigen.
Das ist meine interne Domain, ja.
Also was heißt intern?
Die habe ich mir gekauft, aber die verwende ich nur intern.
Markbrech, danke für den Sub.
Das ist das Teil, was so heiß geworden ist ohne Kühlung, genau.
Und guck mal, die gleiche SSD, die hat das letzte Mal am 100 Grad Limit gekratzt.
Jetzt habe ich schon wieder zugemacht.
Und hier in dieser Erweiterungskarte dank dem Kühler bleibt es jetzt halt bei 60 Grad,
maximal 70 Grad, was vollkommen in Ordnung ist.
Nein, unraid.net verwende ich nicht.
Ich verwende garantiert keine Cloud-Integration, um einen Surfer mit Zertifikaten auszustatten
und irgendwelche Geschichten zu sünden in die Cloud.
Also gerade deswegen habe ich das, dass ich kein Cloud-Geschäft brauche.
Also unraid.net kommt bei mir nicht in die Tüte.
Das habe ich auch gesehen.
Ich fand es von der Idee her ganz nett.
Aber mal davon abgesehen, ich will eh eine Reverse-Box, die davor haben,
vor den ganzen Docker-Containern, da kann er auch Let's Encrypt mitmachen.
Aber unraid.net will ich nicht.
So, jetzt habe ich euch das gezeigt.
Also ihr seht, es flutscht.
Hast du vor, Nextcloud aufzusetzen?
Ich hoffe, ich bin Nextcloud los jetzt endlich.
Also ich habe ja Nextcloud noch am Laufen auf meiner aktuellen Kiste.
Unter anderem für den Kalender und für Termine und halt hauptsächlich für paar Dateien zum Sünden.
Aber Nextcloud fuckt mich so ab.
Ich will kein Nextcloud mehr.
Also ich hoffe, dass ich das jetzt, wenn ich das umstelle auf die neue Kiste hier, endlich los werde.
Ja und wann ich das umstelle ist noch gar nicht klar.
Ich bastel jetzt erstmal ein bisschen rum.
Das ist natürlich auch vielleicht ein bisschen missverständlich gewählter Domain nach.
Ja, doch, es gibt Alternativen zu Nextcloud, aber halt nicht in diesem Gesamtkonstrukt.
Also wenn du Nextcloud verwendest und alles davon verwendest plus eventuell noch Nextcloud Talk
oder irgendwelche Zusatzapps oder sowas, dann kommst du da nicht dran vorbei.
Wenn du aber einfach nur einen CalDAV Server brauchst oder sagen wir mal so nicht mehr CalDAV,
wenn du in irgendeiner Art und Weise Termine und Kontakte sharen willst und unabhängig davon auch
Dateien synchronisieren möchtest, dann gibt es verschiedene Alternativen.
Du kannst nix beliebigen CalDAV Server nehmen, plus Syncthing zum Beispiel oder was weiß ich,
Z-File oder Dropbox, keine Ahnung, gibt ja durchaus genug andere Sachen.
Leute, um um die Geschwindigkeit zu testen, also ich habe euch ja gerade gezeigt,
ETH Tool gesynced sind wir mit 10 Gigabit, aber ich würde jetzt gerne mal testen,
wie schnell wir wirklich sind.
Deswegen muss ich meine alte 4 HE 8 Kern Xeon Kiste nochmal aktivieren.
Nicht Rechenzentrum Server Raum ist das Ding.
Das da, das da, das was man hier unten liegen sieht.
Die alte Kiste mit dem 8 Xeon D drinne muss ich reaktivieren, weil die hat 2 C Gigabit Interfaces
und damit können wir schön testen, wie schnell die Datenübertragung zwischen der Kiste geht
oder der Türstopper genau zwischen der Kiste geht und dem alten Teil.
Warum ich es nicht mit meinem Desktop mache, das kann ich euch auch sagen.
Ich habe nämlich das letzte Mal, haben wir hier mit dem Desktop 10 Gigabit Datenübertragung gemacht,
dann ist mein Stream abgekackt.
Das war zu viel.
Da konnte ich nicht mehr streamen dabei.
Deswegen, die CPU bottleneck, nö da bottleneck nix.
Also wir probieren, wir probieren ein paar Sachen aus.
Wir machen zuerst mal die übliche Geschichte, Iperf und sonst was
und dann mal einen Summer Mount machen und gucken, wie schnell man darüber einfach nur Nullen schreiben kann und so was.
Mal gucken, mal gucken.
Dazu müssen wir aber erst mal, 1, 2, 2, 1, 6, 8, wo ist denn das Admin Interface von diesem Ding?
Da.
Da müssen wir erst mal ein Ubuntu Server draufhauen, weil ich habe nichts installiert auf der alten 8 Kern Kiste.
Die hatten wir zwar das letzte Mal, aber ich habe alles, ich habe sogar den RAM ausgebaut.
Ich musste den RAM erst wieder einbauen kurz vorm Stream.
Ich habe das Ding gestartet und er hat nur noch gepiepst.
Und da habe ich reingehört und gesagt, ah, ich habe den RAM ausgebaut schon.
Also das Ding war quasi kurz vorm Dachboden.
Ich schmeiße ja sowas nicht weg, solange es auch gut ist, das stabelt sich dann auf dem Dachboden.
Warum geht denn das Management Interface nicht?
Chat, sagt mal.
Wer von euch hat es kaputt gemacht?
Wer war es?
Gebt euch zu erkennen.
Sus.
Warte mal, habe ich den Strom überhaupt an?
Ah, ich habe das Netzteil ausgeschaltet, okay.
Das Netzteil ist aus, alles klar.
Gut, easy.
Piep, piep, piep.
Jetzt ist das Netzteil wieder an.
Mal gucken, was das Management Interface pinkt.
Und dann schauen wir.
Ein bisschen mehr trinken hier.
Wir müssen Hydrated Stain.
Suche auf LDLC ist voll im Arsch.
Kann sein, ich wusste nach, was ich suchen muss.
Das ist Mario Kart Musik.
Warum sind Management Interfaces immer so hyper, High Speed, Hyperspeed, schnell.
Oh, hört ihr es Leute, hier.
Der Lüfter ist gerade volle Pulle angegangen.
Ach nee, ihr hört es nicht.
Ihr hört es nicht, weil ich die High IQ Rauschunterdrückung an habe.
Filter.
Super, jetzt ist der Lüfter gerade wieder ausgegangen.
Ja, dann nicht.
Ah, guck mal, das Management Interface ist da.
Wir haben es geschafft.
Jawoll, lock dich ein.
Leute, jetzt müsst ihr stark sein.
Wir brauchen Java Web Start für das Management Interface von der Ollen Kiste.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Sehe ich da Lock4j?
Wahrscheinlich ist das Ding Lock4j anfällig, würde mich nicht wundern.
So, er hat ins BIOS gebootet, wahrscheinlich weil er keine bootbare Platte gefunden hat.
Habe ich hier irgendwo ein aktuelles Ubuntu Server Download?
Sollte sich doch schnell installieren lassen.
Wobei, Leute, wartet mal.
Ich habe doch ein PXE.
Ich habe doch ein PXE bei mir hier laufen.
Sollte der nicht PXE booten können?
Pause Champ?
Ah, der macht UEFI Boot.
Ah, mein PXE kann kein UEFI Boot.
Paints Champ.
Kann er Legacy Boot machen?
Kann man eben irgendwie sagen, Legacy, Legacy, Legacy...
Legacy Netzwerk Boot.
Wo stelle ich das denn ein?
Kannst du glaube umstellen?
Ja, wo?
Security?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Advanced?
Main?
System Configuration?
Inboot?
Ah ja.
Boot from LAN?
Ja, ja, ja.
Ich weiß doch nicht, wo ich mein SFP drinnen habe.
Und wo kann man da Legacy machen?
Vielleicht gar nicht, hä?
Weißt du was?
Scheiß drauf.
Ich lad mir jetzt ein Ubuntu runter, installieren das hier übers ILO.
Mit Ubuntu Server, alles klar.
Ah, wo ist denn der Download?
Manuelle Installation.
LTS, gib ihm.
Wunderbar.
Hopp.
Auf.
Save.
Gut.
Media?
Virtual Media?
Wizard?
Warum bist denn du so langsam?
Na gut, 22 MB die Sekunde ist durchaus in Ordnung für ein Download.
Wir machen das.
Scheiß auf PXE.
Wobei mich interessiert es jetzt doch.
Mich interessiert es, wie ich...
Mich interessiert es tatsächlich brennend.
Ich glaube ich bin auf PXE 1.
Ich installiert es brennend, ob ich PXE booten kann.
Wir probieren es jetzt aus.
Ich mein, scheiß drauf.
Einfach mal ausprobieren.
Vielleicht kann er ja PXE booten.
Wenn nicht, starte ich es neu mit dem ISO-Train und gut ist.
Wir müssen jetzt eh warten, bis er das ISO runtergeladen hat.
Was macht das?
Was macht das da eigentlich für Dinger?
DXE PCIe Bus Enamoration.
Alright, alles klar.
Boot?
Leute...
Ah, ich war zu langsam.
Ich hätte CTRL S drücken sollen zum booten, oder?
Bootmenü 11.
Ist das die Netzwerkkarte?
Guck mal, der versucht bei PXE zu starten.
Was?
PXE Unload?
Api-Call failed.
Okay.
Du hast nie einen Hauch Ahnung, was passiert, ich auch nicht.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was der da macht.
Ich versuche gerade übers Netzwerk zu installieren, weil ich hatte mir mal hier vor Monaten mal
ein PXE Server drauf geklatscht, dass ich übers Netzwerk installieren kann, aber anscheinend
funktioniert das nicht.
Was macht es hier eigentlich?
Also was bin ich sehend gerade?
Er hat prinzipiell schon mal gesagt PXE, also er hat schon was gefunden, aber der versucht
EFI zu booten, obwohl es EFI nicht gibt bei mir zum booten per PXE.
Ja, wie dem auch sei.
Also wir machen jetzt mal Media, wir schmeißen mal die Ubuntu.
Guck mal, was wir für tolle Ordner haben.
KegW, KegW3, KegW, MonkaS.
Alles da, Downloads.
Der Chubuntu Server, da ist er, connect.
Meint ihr, es geht noch weiter oder der hängt jetzt da auf immer und ewig?
Ja, ich machs mit net.xy.
Ich glaube, ich hab keine EFI-Boot-Geschichte hinterlegt, nur normales Legacy-Boot.
Stop, das hängt.
Können wir booten jetzt?
Ctrl, Alt, Entf, Entf, nein geht nicht.
Dann machen wir jetzt Restart Server, yes.
Dann hinterlegt das doch, das ist nicht so einfach.
Da muss ich mal ne Router-Config und ihm sagen, wo das ausgeliefert wird und bla und sonst was.
Dann installier ichs lieber jetzt über das RSA gemountete Ding.
Oder...
Ctrl, Alt, Ctrl, Alt.
Show Setup Prompt, nein, BXE.
No other choice, super.
Die ISO, ja, das ist ne super Idee, das mach ich, ISO Netboot XYZ.
Das ist wahrscheinlich noch besser, ja, hast du recht.
Das ist tatsächlich noch besser, hier ISO.
Das geht nämlich bestimmt schneller per Netzwerkinstallation als der andere Shit.
Da kann ich nämlich übers Netzwerk installieren, muss nicht über dieses dumme iDRAC.
Ja, kann ich jetzt Escape machen oder bootet weiter?
Und bootet per USB 11, F11, USB, Boot, USB, USB, CD.
Ah, das sieht gut aus.
Der File Pro sein, das ist Java Shit.
Da sind wir doch, also, was wollen wir haben?
Free DOS, genau, Free DOS unbedingt.
Linux Network Installs, Chubuntu.
20.04, jawoll. Warum haben die eigentlich kein 21.10 da drin?
Ja, das ist das, das ist der Swing File Browser.
Der ist wahrscheinlich genauso kacke zu programmieren, wie er aussieht.
Ich hab das noch nie benutzt, ich weiß es nicht, aber ich vermute das einfach mal.
Dass der genauso eklig zu programmieren ist wie die Optik.
Was ist das für ein Programm?
Das ist das Remote Interface von der Kiste, wo wir gerade drauf sind.
Das ist ein Browser, mit Java, mit Java Geschiss von vor 10 Jahren.
So, wir wollen das in Englisch installieren, ja.
Wir sind aber nicht selbst in England, wir sind in, nein.
Wir sind auch nicht, also, wir sind in Europa, wir sind in Germany.
Lokale Settings, ist okay, ich will plus mein Tastatur, yes.
Wir haben auch einen, no, continue.
Wir müssen jetzt mal kurz die Ubuntu Installation durchhemmern.
Damit wir Geschwindigkeitstests machen können.
Ich werde dann von der Kiste hier, auf die Kiste hier,
mal ein bisschen Netzwerkgeschwindigkeit testen.
Mit IPERF oder Net...
Wie heißt das andere Ding, ist auch egal.
Ich kann mir die Syntax davon eh nicht merken.
so primary network interface ja ist jetzt das erste oder das zweite wo ich dran bin
ich vermute mal ich vermute mal das gucken wir mal ob es funktioniert
ok hat funktioniert also war es das richtige interface hostname test jubandu
germany ist gut jawoll ja mit mit 1204 gibt es jetzt dieses komische automate
also dieses neue server setup das das mit dem schwarzen hintergrund und so das mag
ich überhaupt nicht ich weiß nicht hat irgendjemanden plan was die jungs bei
canonical also die die ubuntu buster was sie an diesem installations interface so kacke fanden
dass die jetzt das neue machen mussten was ich persönlich schlechter finde welche cpu das
ist ein xeon e 2224 glaube ich das ist hier übrigens nicht der hp server das ist ein anderer
full name max yes 123456 highly secure passwörter immer verwenden jetzt wie passport absolut in
ordnung timezone ist auch correct also guckt euch mal diesen installer an ubuntu server install und
jetzt vergleich den mal mit dem neuen das ist der neue also ich weiß nicht also irgendwie komme ich
mit dem installer viel besser zurecht als mit dem der neue geht ein bisschen schneller ja gut ok ja
mal ok macht mag sein wenn man viele server installiert aber dann macht man es wahrscheinlich
ähnlich von hand mit dem installer durchklicken der neue ist einem snap package allein schon das
wäre eigentlich ein grund dafür den alten weiter zu verwenden alter snap pains jam ja ja guide disc
500g vollkommen in ordnung sollte uns reichen yes der 20er hatte das auch schon ja aber hier
bieten sie vielleicht gab es für den 20er noch das alte zur auswahl und ab dem 21er nicht mehr
feature auswahl gibt sie ja auch aber ganz ehrlich ich verwende weder bei red hat die
feature auswahl noch bei ubuntu das einzige was ich bei beiden mache beim installieren ist
ssh server alles andere mache ich selbst verwendet jemand von euch die feature auswahl im installer
also wer das nicht kennt es gibt so einen moment ich zeige euch das mal gibt's bestimmt bilder
von ubuntu server feature select ja da kann man also sachen auswählen wie kubernetes cluster
und ja da kann man so sachen auswählen wie ich will ein kubernetes cluster ich will ein docker
installiert haben ich will irgendwie eine postgres datenbank oder sowas ich will kipa life in prometos
drauf haben ich verwende das nie ich macht wie gesagt nur ssh ich mach immer ssh drauf das
mache ich bei red halt auch so aber ansonsten habe ich weder dort noch beim was andere auch bei
debia nicht diesen feature diesen feature bei debia die haben ja auch so was irgendwie task
select oder so verwende ich auch nie und die schlimmste entscheidung bei ubuntu war ja immer
noch diesen komischen netplan geschichte ich meine wer braucht ernsthaft jammel für seine
netzwerk konfig das sind snap packages das kann ich mir gut vorstellen wusste ich nicht dass
es snap packages sind aber im zweifelsfall so wie ich die kenne bei ubuntu snap packages
so gleich ist installiert these are popular snaps ja allein schon dass es snap sind ist
ein weiterer grund dass ich nicht niemals verwenden werde ich hasse snap
leute ich hole mal kurz was zu trinken
wieder da leute wollt ihr mal den schönen schönen server sound hören
ja sekunde server sound nur für euch eine runde server sound
jetzt erst mal wieder alles schön neu sup suppressed so automatic updates ich verwende
auch kein flatt pack ganz ehrlich ich verwende ich verwende auch archlinux by the way dann
nehme ich einfach user packages und alles ist gut und jetzt kommen die leute die sagen max man
jaro ist keine archlinux wie immer immer die gleichen diskussionen hier auf ins installier
mal nach hinne oh wir haben es geschafft nice basic ssh basic ubuntu server ja meinetwegen
macht ein basic ubuntu server gendu ist das eigentlich gendu oder gentoo die
coolen leute sprechen es bestimmt gentoo aus oder also ich muss sagen der
netzwerk installer geht dreimal so schnell wie der usb installer ja snap habt ihr es gesehen
warum ok ich habe ja auch gesagt er soll ein ubuntu server installieren da ist natürlich
snap dabei was sonst weiß auch nicht was sie sich in südafrika da gedacht haben snap mit
snap zu lull so haben wir es jetzt installiert so wie hat ein ipad noch mal funktioniert das
kann ich mir nie merken ich brauche das oft genug dass ich weiß dass es das gibt und grob
wie es funktioniert aber selten genug dass ich mir die parameter merken kann ich glaube ipad
fx oder so muss man starten auf der einen seite und ipad c oder so auf der anderen ach
kriegen wir raus kriegen wir nicht minus x minus s war es genau minus s nicht mit
minus x minus s ja weißt du was das zulu in zulu bedeutet ich kenne wie fanzulu minus
r ist reverse genau das ist in die andere richtung checkt so wir haben es geschafft
yes krabb installieren auf auf und dann rippen warum ist meine ssd sdd und ich esse die a oder
b wenigsten so ab was ich hinterfragt das gar nicht immer davon aus das funktioniert jetzt so
jetzt muss ich das media erstmal disconnecten wenn er fertig mit der installation ist wobei eigentlich
kann ich jetzt schon disconnecten weil den hallo nach da das brauche ich bestimmt nicht mehr so
remove continue auf booten please was jetzt auch eine manjaro def vm beste ist jetzt auch
archlinux by the way du musst jetzt aber auch jedem erzählen dass du das verwendest das ist
wichtig also das ist eine der grundvoraussetzungen sobald man irgendwie auch nur auch nur ansatzweise
was mit archlinux zu tun hat muss man das der welt mitteilen alternativ windows benutzer und
linux benutzer also windows benutzer musst du mitteilen dass es unter linux e alles besser ist
arch by the way und linux benutzer die nicht archlinux verhält muss natürlich auch erzählen
dass es besser ist als ihren kram nein du sollst kein px e boot machen alle kack zack server power
reset so bootmenü please warum ist die ssd bitteschön nicht nicht als erstes beim booten drin was das
für ein blödsinn ssd muss als erstes gebootet werden warum ist netzwerk in der gut das netzwerk
boot zuerstes verstehe ich sogar egal ich mache jetzt bootmenü und statt von der ssd und alles
gut bootmenü go go go bootmenü habe ich eigentlich das wieder eingeschaltet den filter
so wir booten von der ssd wo ist meine ssd wo
was wo ist die ssd
ubuntu in legacy installiert manche muss die ssd doch finden die kriegt anfälle ich will
ein fucking ubuntu ins kann sein dass es mit einer halben stunde dauert gut
gut options wollen die mich verarschen wo ist meine ssd ok legacy boot muss ich jetzt
muss ich wirklich legacy boot anmachen ja was ist das wieder für ein shit gut options usb
wie hat jemand eine glorreiche idee wie ich legacy boot anmachen in boot ist es nicht in boot
würde man es erwarten dass es boot legacy ist aber wie mache ich legacy boot an mein gott
warum dauert das shit schon wie das das nervt mich dass so sachen so unnötig die sachen
so ewig lang dauern wie mache ich legacy boot an usb konfig ah legacy usb mode
legacy only
es sollte ein ok
es funktioniert doch jetzt bestimmt auch nicht oder
was bedeutet denn csm
ssd muss richtig drin stecken da habe ich was drauf installiert außerdem steckt in den wechsel
rahmen festgeschraubt drinne die kann er richtig nicht nicht richtig drin stecken
du du du du du so gut mit dir
meine fucking ssd steht nicht drinne was ist das denn ich habe immer auf der ssd was drauf
installiert warum steht die ssd da nicht drin was für ein shit
muss ich jetzt noch mal installieren oder was
ist das für ein schrott
das ist damit du bios media mit anu efe booten kannst
keine ahnung warum das nicht drinne steht
ok media
downloads ubuntu installer
es überhaupt kein bock drauf ich wollte mich da eigentlich mit jetzt gar nicht ewig aufhalten
legacy only ist falsch ja weiß ich nicht ich habe vorher beides drinne gaben da war es auch
nicht da dann zählen wir den scheiß jetzt halt noch mal die ssd ist nicht kaputt es ergibt
keinen sinn warum die ssd kaputt sein sollte mitnehmen die legacy option es gibt keiner der
dadurch blickt ich mache mir gleich nur bunte usb stick und steckt den da rein und dann wird
davon gebootet das habt ihr jetzt jetzt habt ihr wenigstens auch mal den direkten vergleich
klein mit dem alten und dem neuen ubuntu installer den scheiß jetzt noch mal installieren muss
usb cd ja was sie sich mit den legacy optionen gedacht hat das der neue ubuntu installer und man
sieht dass man nichts sieht was ist ein gutes live live linux man könnte noch wir könnten
auch einfach hier ubuntu live drauf drauf starten tails knobbix gibt's knobbix noch gibt's knobbix
noch ist booted ok download knobbix von wann ist das letzte knobbix was ist was ist denn
das hier jetzt schon wieder boah geht mir das auf den sack schon wieder dass der kram nicht
einfach funktionieren kann ich hab's installiert er ist der meinung es ist durch aber nein es
bootet nicht ich glaube am storage controller war boot ausgestellt ne die hängt nicht am
intel controller die hängt am onboard rate controller und der habe ich nichts umgestellt
ich meine ich habe da vorher auch immer von gebootet was checking it integrity nein alter
immer weg das ist einfach das setup starten und gut ist ich bin schon wieder richtig richtig
sauer auf den kram warum kann es nicht einfach funktionieren warum installiert man nicht
was und es booted danach und es funktioniert ich brauch das noch nicht mal ich brauch das
noch nicht dass ich kann er nichts auswerfen das ist eine locaten das ist ein sata ssd ich
brauche das nur zum testen ich will das für nix anderes verwenden es ist kein marvel controller
guckt euch das guckt euch das eland an alter ubuntu server man das ist doch nicht mein
usb stick das ist übers elo gemounted ok wie kriege ich da jetzt irgendwas lauffähiges
auf die schnelle drauf ich brauche das zum testen immer ein knobbix das ist doch hier
das ist doch verarschung wieder guckt euch das hier an kann es ja immer abbrechen gibt
das nicht gibt es das nicht vielleicht auch ganz einfach per ganz normal im download ok
knobbix knobbix em iso 4g ja perfekt wunderbar auch einfach nur ein net perf und die möglichkeit
samba sachen zu mounten mehr nicht das wars und warum standardmäßig das iso integrity
die gecheckt werden muss gut meinetwegen netbook den übers stimmt wir können über netbooten
live iso bauten das ist eine sehr gute idee das mache ich also der kriegt jetzt hier zeit
mit seinem integrity check bis der download fertig ist vom knobbix vier minuten wenn das
bis dahin ist ich meine mehr als abbrechen kann ich ja nicht doch wie viel starten wir
haben kein bock virtual media media java java geh weg wie kriege ich das weg ja ja disconnect
netboot connect server reboot ich will eigentlich gar nichts damit machen ich brauche einfach
eine kiste wo ich ein perf drauf ausführen kann mit zehn gigabit ich will jetzt keine
drei stunden darauf irgendwas installieren eigentlich was ganz anderes machen das ist
übrigens auch was was mich auf der arbeit und ich habe damit glücklicherweise so gut
wie nix zu tun aber wenn ich sehe nervt mich immer dass diese ganze business enterprise
server geschichten immer 30 stunden booten und das ist jetzt schon schnell ihr müsstet
euch mal frühere frühere IBM server angucken die hat hier hatte jemand mal das glück mit
den mit IBM hs 21 blades zu arbeiten als die neu waren die dinge haben oder es ist kein
mit die haben drei bis fünf minuten gebootet bis die beim boot manager waren das ist kein
mit das ist so schlecht eigentlich
warum geht es nicht mal mehr das netboot das ging doch eben noch
der fuck alter ich check es nicht mehr
das hat doch eben auch schon funktioniert
warum geht das jetzt immer das haben wir doch eben gerade schon gestartet available interfaces
aber ich habe ich in bios netzwerk ausgeschaltet oder sowas ok leute wir können uns darauf einstellen
es dauert von fünf stunden das zu testen habe ich irgendwas ausgeschaltet ok wir kommen
mal ins bios bios f2 f2 nee ich habe nicht auf legacy boot gestellt und ich habe wieder
zurückgestellt boot das hier habe ich ausgeschaltet aber das kann es doch jetzt nicht sein oder
das ist dass der selbst px eboot probiert aber wir machen ja kein px eboot ja das ist
ätzend das so das ist ja eigentlich schon eine kleinigkeit das ich brauche das ding
ja eigentlich gar nicht also doch für einen bandbreiten test jetzt aber ich hatte jetzt
nicht vor da eine stunde mit rum zu machen bis da was drauf läuft passende musik im
hintergrund rau rau rau rau rau rau rau rau rau rau rau rau rau rau rau rau rau rau rau
bootmenü ok normix ist fertig ja das machen als nächstes bootmenü booten von cd habe
ich das jetzt hier gemontet auch guck mal ich habe netboot als cd gemontet alles klar
klaus cd ok ich muss wirklich die netzwerkarte als boot device dass es geht alles klar das
hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht ok live cds was nehmen wir da knobbix manjaro ubuntu was
haben wir hier als live cd hatte hatte knobbix es gibt noch nicht mal einen knobbix debian
ist auch ok debian live ist core nur terminal terminal würde mir ja reichen ssr server starten
und gut ist er brauche ich ja nicht pass auf jetzt hat debian für meine netzwerkarte kein
treiber oder sowas weil es zu alt ist ich trau den alles zu
was exactly macht er da jetzt der lädt wahrscheinlich den kram in ram gerade weil das läuft ja
alles aus dem ram die live cds also wahrscheinlich muss er das erstmal entpacken oder so was
das für netboot ding das netboot xyz also mini iso oder alternativ kannst du auch pxe
booten und dann kannst du den rest übers netzwerk laden ist eigentlich sehr praktisch nice da
sind wir ja mein funkt ich kann ich bei enter drücken mein klasser kontrol z moment kontrol
c kann ich drücken aber sonst nix was ist das ich krieg anfälle
warum kann ich nix tippen auf dem keyboard mann keyboard ich hatte doch eben so komisches
on board keyboard wo ist es denn wo war denn das leute ich hatte doch ich hab doch eben
so ein komisches keyboard ja das tippt auch nix ok mein enter geht ok alter java shit man
update jetzt installieren wir erst mal den ssh und dann komm ab install open ssh so jetzt
mann also was ein dreck mann was war das problem keine ahnung 2 mal rein 15 mal rein und raus
geklickt und dann gehts so hat sich das ding keine dhcp adresse geholt es wird ja es wird
immer besser mann jedoch hat's doch ich hab zwei ip adressen auf einmal warum hab ich
zwei ist mir egal hauptsache eine davon geht ok achso ist es nicht gestartet system system
ctl sshd ah ne start sshd tja was ist denn pass midi pass pass midi oh jetzt ist root
password noch verboten ich sag's euch etc sshd etc ssh sshd config root root permit
root login wa wa wa
ja ja ok
achso ich hab die terminals gerade durchgeschaltet
was so yes yes yes please lasst mich einfach nur raus und
speichern ja darf ich jetzt restart mann was ist das hier alter was zum teufel ist das
für nen shit wer von euch ist das die hacker bands ok restart sshd darf ich jetzt mich
drauf einloggen als gut bitte bitte einfach gut einloggen ja ich hab's geschafft ich
hab's geschafft ich bin ich kann endlich zeug drauf machen da ist ok das hier muss jetzt
ganz schnell irgendwie auf desktop acht oder so dass ich nicht mehr sehen muss update nein
nein wir machen kein up install ipad heißt es einfach so ipad warum ist eigentlich immer
noch ipad 2 drauf so ipad minus s ne wir machen das anders wir machen es erstmal hier
auf also ipad ist nicht drauf ok unrate plugins nord tools ipad yes apply ist auch ein ziemlich
hässlicher package manager aber immerhin gibt es ein ipad minus s ok ipad minus c 122 162
148 das ist schnell guck mal hier das flutscht das dürfte ich mein theoretisch kannst du
maximale übertragungs rate hast du bei 10 g hast du dann quasi was ist 10 g maximal
1125 mb 1250 mb ne ich glaub 1250 mb oder maximal also das ist schon würde ich sagen
ziemlich gut also geschwindigkeitstechnisch kann man sich hier echt nicht beschweren oder
vollkommen in ordnung so machen wir es mal reverse auch ok also damit kann ich leben
damit kann ich leben ich gehe mal davon aus dass du wirklich das absolut maximum rauskriegst
müsstest du auch deine 100 frames ein bisschen größer machen also die mtu ein bisschen
nee nee ist es die mtu nee ist nicht die mtu ist das frame das ist die frame größe
weiß nicht wie man das nennt jumbo frames genau also 9000 bytes statt 1500 oder so aber
chat was sagt ihr also ich finde es in ordnung ist in ordnung oder so jetzt müssen wir noch
mal was anderes testen wir müssen nämlich mal die bandbreite ausprobieren wenn ich
hier ich mache das mal kurz hier unten auf ipad minus s und jetzt mal das machen wir
müssen mal die bandbreite checken ja vollkommen in ordnung so absolut absolut top kann man
sich nicht beschweren wir müssen nämlich mal die bandbreite ausprobieren wenn es die
ssd wenn die ssd was schafft und es übers netzwerk geht wie schnell es dann noch geht
also wir machen jetzt ssd volle pulle genau ssd volle pulle und jetzt machen wir hier
mal zu
ex oh ok ex post guck mal wenn die wenn die ssd brummt dann ist die übertragungsrate
nicht mehr so hoch aha ip league monka es interessant so das heißt als nächstes probieren
wir mal ganz normal ins samba mount aus wie schnell das ist shares isos ja meinetwegen
wie macht man jetzt hier überhaupt noch mal ordentliche cash yes shares wie schert man
das jetzt samba samba shares isos export jetzt security public apply so von der idee her
muss ich jetzt eigentlich isos ja alles klar so samba mount ach gott das ist auch was
ich nicht mal was ich nicht was mount zips ab install ne zips ne was muss man dafür installieren
einfach samba samba samba client oder so kommen zips utils no zips utils ah so war das
ok mount zips nach mnt bett das das werde ich glaube ich nie beim ersten mal hinbekommen
password gibt kein password permission denied na geil options minus o anonymen oder so mount
zips anonymen muss oder gest minus o gest vielleicht gest ah minus o gest muss man machen aha da
sind wir touch 1 2 3 das ist noch mal kurz hier schauen da ist es ok hat funktioniert
yes dann machen wir jetzt hier drüber mal was dann dann dann legen wir jetzt hier drauf
mal was was stale file handle kann ich kein ls machen aufm samba anscheinend nicht das
ist zu advanced ls für den samba mount so pv wir können es auch mal mit dd machen if
gleich def zero of gleich blub punkt bin bs gleich 4096 und was ist das andere status
progress leinschreiben das aber langsam ach nee es ist es ist ein gigabyte es ist ein
gigabyte die sekunde gewesen ok ok dann ist es durchaus in ordnung wie viel auslastung
haben wir hier ja samba ist ziemlich ziemlich am limit naja naja wir lassen es mal kurz
bisschen laufen aber insgesamt ist es doch eigentlich ganz ok ich denke mal mit ein bisschen
gebastelt kriegt man es vielleicht auch noch schneller
aber insgesamt erscheint mir das doch ganz in ordnung zu sein 860 mb die sekunde ist
doch in ordnung ok meine mein lieblings pv test lub ls geht ja nicht habe ich ja ganz
vergessen ab install pv hier wird es richtig warm langsam drinnen ich habe zwei kisten
drum pv blub punkt image def zero ich weiß nicht warum es in meinen samba mounts nicht
geht keine ah das ist witzigerweise langsamer ok ja warum ls nicht geht ich habe kein schimmer
wenn ich ehrlich bin also wir haben plupp punkt bin und plupp punkt image zur auswahl
jetzt kann man nämlich was runter kopieren und gucken wie schnell das dann ist gucken
wie schnell er runter kopiert wartet es auch mal bis des 50 g großes also nicht von windows
aus von windows aus wird es gerade nicht sondern nicht schnell sein außerdem ich übertrag
hier keine 10 g dann kackt mir wieder das stream ab 40 40 ls an mount ich mount es mal neu
vielleicht ach jetzt darf ich jetzt darf ich auch ls machen ok nice gibt es kann cp mittlerweile
progress erst und kann progress ne s cp kriegt das nicht hin aber es ist cp kann man s cp
nicht auch lokal verwenden und und es zeigt progress an ok gut ich meine ich kann es auch
moment ich will es ja gar nicht ich will was mache ich denn ist auch schwachsinn ich will
es tatsächlich die den weil ich will es ja nach der f0 schreiben ich will es ja gar nicht
zwischenspeichern bei mir lokal also mnt blub blub punkt bin out ist der f0 lesen ist schneller
leute lesen ist schneller also schreiben 800 mb die sekunden lesen 900 mb die sekunde ja
kann ich mit leben ehrlich gesagt ist in ordnung ich meine natürlich man kann sich jetzt fragen
warum also da könnte ich auch die normale usb ssd rein machen die ist die ist kein großer
unterschied also ich meine dass ich jetzt die möglichkeit habe mit 2 gigabyte die sekunde
auf die ssd zu lesen und zu schreiben wird jetzt mit 10 g dem 10 g netzwerk interface
nicht so ganz ausgenutzt aber es funktioniert ja hauptsache es geht aber was sagt ihr zu
der geschwindigkeit ich finde das in ordnung finde ich ok also ganz im ernst 900 irgendwas
ja gut jetzt hat es schon gecasht 900 mb die sekunde ist doch in ordnung ohne dass ich
irgendwie was getunet habe von frame größen zusammen bar settings noch sonst irgendwas
ist eigentlich durchaus ok finde ich jetzt ja kann man machen kann ich mit leben so gibt
sonst so irgendwas was für geschwindigkeits mäßig testen soll hat es in nfs hat andere
nfs gut ich meine who cares nfs mal ganz ehrlich macht eh keinen sinn warum sollte ich nfs
verwenden ich verwende kein nfs daheim also muss ich auch nicht testen mit nfs read settings
von right settings von share status exclude disk ash pool hat wie sieht es aus mit vielen
kleinen dateien können wir das jetzt am besten testen wenn viele kleine dateien anlegen das
bringt uns aber wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich was oder also ich meine ich könnte als reingehen
und sagen hatsch 0 bis 10.000 ok das geht nicht so schnell wobei dass ich weiß woran
das liegt das dauert ein bisschen zu lange nicht funktioniert wobei das liegt glaube
ich am touch mit idee und block size ja also kleine dateien also tausend also tausend
dateien anlegen ist schon ziemlich lahm guckt euch das mal an braucht ungefähr zwei sekunden
tausend dateien anlegen aber das ist wahrscheinlich samba overhead da wirst wahrscheinlich nicht
wirklich viel dran ändern können idee und block size da hast du recht idee ja gut wir
können die block size irgendwie mal größer machen 10.000 oder so jetzt flutscht 10.000
block size 1g die sekunde mehr geht nicht durch idee und jetzt das ganze noch mal schreiben
oh flutscht auch ne geht wieder runter auf das übliche
aber trotzdem ist in ordnung ist ok also glaube da kann ich mich nicht beschweren dass
es in irgendeiner art und weise zu lahm wäre oder so sensors temperatur ist auch im rahmen
44 grad cpu ok passt so was ist chat irgendwas überlege jetzt mein main pc ne ne ne ne
mach das bloß nicht also es sei denn also wenn du was spielen willst lass es sein ich
weiß es gibt hier viele im chat die jetzt sagen wollen das geht aber glaub mir die
probleme ist es nicht wert fängt ja schon an damit dass du einen zweiten monitor brauchst
und eine zweite maus dafür oder du dich mit so was wie looking class auseinander setzen
musst oder so also das willst du nicht das willst du nicht das ist so ein typischer fall
von ja das ist möglich aber ich man muss nicht alles machen was möglich ist behalte
ein windows rechner wenn du es zum spielen brauchst und benutzen wofür er gut ist geiles
anders genau würde ich nicht machen so ok also wir haben performance getestet performance
mäßig kann ich mich nicht beschweren warum auch immer iperf warum ist denn iperf eigentlich
so langsam mein samba ist schneller als iperf das kann doch eigentlich nicht sein oder ich
muss bestimmt aber iperf da gibt es bestimmt settings 10g test da muss man bestimmt auch
udp tests machen oder frame size angeben oder irgendwas in der richtung udp performance
messen ok probier was man mit udp performance ok geht nicht denied reicht das wenn man server
macht und man muss es dann nur noch auf dem client angeben beim 3er minus u ach doch so
schnell ein mbit leben am limit hier würde ich sagen ach da muss man angeben was man
haben will ok ok gigabit jetzt das sind gigabit verliert er nix und jetzt 10 gigabit ich muss
sagen also 1g 10g ok der udp test ist bullshit das ergibt keinen sinn das ergibt keinen
sinn warum ist der udp test langsamer als der als der tcp test ich glaube das kann
sie knicken hinweise für 10g tests gibt es irgendwelche parameter die man dafür verwenden
sollte simultaneous connections ja nee keine ahnung p5 ja gut da kriegt er natürlich
nicht so viel drüber weil gigabit sagen wir so 10g bleiben 10g aber man kann es vielleicht
besser ausnutzen so ja aber ich bin da ich bin da wirklich zufrieden mit es ist jetzt
guck mal vollkommen in ordnung 9,5g kriegen wir drüber von 10g was willst du dich da
was willst du groß machen ist vollkommen vollkommen ok gut hätten wir das auch also dann können
wir uns jetzt ja mal ein paar addons widmen bevor wir jetzt hier noch uns weiter aufhalten
mit irgendwelchen performance tests und sowas also ich würde sagen performance ist im grünen
bereich alles in ordnung die kiste schalte ich hier mal aus leute bevor ich die kiste
ausschalte bevor ich sonst wieder bevor ich gleich wieder ausrasten muss beim einschalten
haben wir noch irgendwelche anderen performance dinger die wir checken wollen fällt euch
fällt euch noch irgendwas ein wir haben ein perf gemacht landen bei ungefähr 9,5g wir
haben samba gemacht landen bei klatten 10g warum auch immer samba schneller ist als
ein perf ich weiß es nicht sonst noch was vpn nö vpn müssen wir nicht testen also ich
werde darauf kein vpn verwenden und wenn ist glaube ich 10g über vpn dann etwas zu optimistisch
stress hat bestimmt iow kram ja aber ich weiß ich irgendwie weiß ich es lohnt über den
samba share iow kram wirklich zu testen mein das touchen von 1000 dateien dauert schon
zwei sekunden nee ich glaube das war es power off kiste aus sehr gut so das hat funktioniert
dann widmen wir uns mal ein paar addons also so wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe mache
also wie mir das vorschwebt kann ich keinen run crisis also mein unrate nicht aber patrick
hat glaube ich ein unrate mit einer durchgereichten gtx frag mich nicht das kann crisis spielen
oder das kann crisis runnen ob du es drauf spielen kannst ist fragwürdig aber es kann
es kann es runnen wasserdringen so weiter im text also wie mir das ganze vorsteht vorsteht
ist folgendes ich will rebuild nee ich will darauf laufen lassen im endeffekt den ganzen
krempel den ich jetzt auf der anderen hardware laufen lassen habe also ich brauche eine
reverse proxy für letzte klubzertifikate ich brauche eine vm mit home assistant ein
altmiddagsschlaf genau das bräuchten wir eigentlich auch als ausrote zeichnen kommand
mein wiki und als nix nix großartig wildes was ich mit dem was ich in dem einen video
gezeigt habe ich werde wahrscheinlich nx verwenden weil es gerade im chat kommt traffic habe
ich aktuell auf meiner kiste aber auf der aktuellen kiste ist es ein docker kompost setup
wo das mit traffic easy relativ easy zu konfigurieren ist hier werde ich es wahrscheinlich anders
machen nee wahrscheinlich nicht swag wahrscheinlich nx proxy manager das werden wir jetzt mal
ausprobieren gucken ob das ob das funktioniert ja schauen wir mal und wichtig ich hatte am
anfang ein problem dass der die docker container und vms auf die platte gespeichert hat und
nicht auf cash nx als reverse proxy und zwar damit das habe ich mir im vorfeld aber schon
mal angeguckt ich kenne das ich kenne das ich habe das im vorfeld schon mal ausprobiert
schon voll voll vor längerer zeit auch immer mal wieder das ding fand ich eigentlich gar
nicht schlecht ich meine es wird nicht so einfach sein wie mein aktuelles docker kompost setup
aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen so ganz happy bin ich mit der konp mit dieser konfiguration
auch nicht es ist zwar nice dass docker container automatisch gebalanced werden trotzdem ist
es nicht so wirklich automatisch weil du musst ein label setzen und zusätzliche configs
die kann ich mir auch in einem gui zusammen klicken es ist trotzdem nicht komplett automatisch
deswegen probieren wir das mal damit aus ach ja und ihr seht übrigens in weiser voraussicht
ich habe meine ports von unrate schon auf nicht default ports geändert also ich habe
mein unrate auf port 1443 laufen nicht auf 443 weil wenn ich mein unrate auf 443 laufen
habe kann ich natürlich keinen docker container starten auf port 443 dann müsste ich dem docker
container eine andere lp geben dass ich ihm sage hier benutzt mein netzwerkinterface nimm
eine andere lp dann hast du dann aber noch andere probleme weil du noch ein zweites netzwerk
dran hängen musst und sowas was unrate zumindest nicht übers ui unterstützt also das ist das
einfachste setup das habe ich mir im vorfeld schon angeguckt du kannst sagen also ich installiere
das mal erik dankeschön für den zapp ne ich will es nicht vom previous app installieren
ich will es ohne gedürt attention so also man kann sagen ich möchte das also der unterschied
zwischen diesen geschichten ist folgende bridge ist ein ziemlich dover name weil damit
ist nicht deine netzwerk karte gemeint damit ist ein schon für dich angelegtes docker
netzwerk gemeint mit privatem ip raum das ist nicht deine netzwerk karte so dann hast
du host damit verwendest du dann quasi die die gleiche sachen mit von von deinem host
netzwerk technisch oder du kannst sagen br 0 dann kannst du dem container eine neue ip
geben aber aus deinem normalen netzwerk was eben per kabel an deiner netzwerk karte dran
hängt und ich habe in custom netzwerk schon angelegen custom docker netzwerk das ist auch
ein internes docker netzwerk mit interner ip und das nehmen wir jetzt auch dafür fix
ip ist mir egal also web ui auf port 81 htp port auf port 80 ok htps port 443 auch in
ordnung weil ich habe ja meinen container also mein mein host umgelegt auf 1443 das
heißt der port ist frei hoffe ich mal dass sonst nichts ist und ansonsten gib ihm apply
und ich hoffe da hat es meine alten settings auch gelöscht weil ich habe keine bock zeugs
zu liegen mal gucken ob es auf die ssd geht ja es geht auf die ssd weil ansonsten würde
ich jetzt neben mir hören das war mein versuch denn das imitierendste von festplatten sound
so docker läuft alles klar port mappings sind auch da wunderbar das ist die gleiche
ip wie vom unrate jetzt kann man hier um sagen web ui starten und jetzt weiß ich nicht
mehr es war admin change me glaube ich admin at example.com change me ja habe ich richtig
im kopf so jetzt muss man sich irgendwas anderes ausdenken dass es funktioniert also sagen
wir jetzt einfach mal zum beispiel cute chat unsere geilen unsere geilen fake email adressen
die wir hatten jesus.ru cute chat jesus.ru nein das wollen wir nicht add pricechamp.org
oder irgendwas ist ja auch egal admin password ganz super komplexes password change me aktuelles
password 123456 was was ist hier los warum darf ich nicht meine super secure passwörder
verwenden will er mir ernsthaft sagen 123456 ist kein gutes password das ist doch best
practice 123456 zu nehmen 123456789 123456789 ha outplayed ok so wie ging das jetzt nochmal
proxy host dashboard ja ich denke mir dass auch die meisten neben 123456 das kann gar
nicht schlecht sein
neun statt acht charakter ja ich habe einen mehr so und jetzt kann man hier sagen ssl
certificate add ssl certificate jetzt muss ich euch glaube ich gleich blören cloudflare
ich habe hier meinen api token das ist übrigens ein fake api token das ist nicht mein api
token ich muss das api token da jetzt irgendwie rein bekommen ohne dass ihr es seht selbst
wenn ihr es seht ich sage das nur für den fall der fälle weil der gleich wieder irgendwelche
leutes ausprobieren müssen ich habe das api token so eingestellt dass es nur funktioniert
wenn man meine public ip verwendet also ihr könnt damit auch so nichts anfangen aber
ich will es trotzdem nicht liegen so normalerweise also wir lassen uns jetzt wildcard zertifikat
ausstellen wildcard zertifikat dafür und da muss jetzt ein api token rein und wie kriege
ich das api token da rein erstmal mache ich das hier drin auf in einem anonymen tab und
mache meine vm aus weil ich habe hier einen clipboard manager der sich das natürlich alles
bespeichert das ist auch doof so jetzt dürft ihr jetzt dürft ihr chat macht ihr die augen
zu nicht gucken nicht gucken jetzt war cute chat 1 2 7 8 9 also ssl zertifikate ok kann
ich euch blurren irgendwie blurr nee so nicht sekunde display capture filter add blur bamm
chat ihr seid geblurt ihr seht nichts mehr also ssl zertifikat so wildcard zertifikat
use dns challenge cloudflare cloudflare api so jetzt kann ich meinen api token kopieren
ohne dass ihr meine api token seht und jetzt sage ich use dns challenge safe ok und wenn
ich glück habe dann geht das wieder und ich endblur euch jetzt so wenn ich das jetzt richtig
eingegeben habe dann sollte ich gleich ein wildcard zertifikat für meine domain haben
es gibt programme die solche weich zeichnen reverse engineer viel spaß das api token
funktioniert nur mit meiner public api und ich lösche nach dem stream viel spaß da
irgendwas zu reverse engineern da sind wir wieder und ich habe wildcard zertifikat für
meine domain so jetzt können wir gleich mal damit anfangen nachdem ich jetzt wildcard
zertifikat für meine domain habe können wir gleich mal damit anfangen den unrate dem
unrate selber das unrate selber zu proxen nein das ist immer noch nicht mein api token
so ssl zertifikat oh mein netzwerk ist noch nicht wieder da mein netzwerk jetzt wieder
da netzwerk da ist mein netzwerk wieder real hacker man reverse engineern das ja viel viel
viel viel erfolgt da was engineern so jetzt können wir nämlich mal gucken ob wir unser
unrate selbst proxen können was natürlich an sich nicht immer funktioniert weil wenn
unrate neu gestartet wird und der container läuft dann kannst du unrate ja auch nicht
über den container proxen da musst du das standardmäßige nehmen aber nur zu gucken
ob es funktioniert also wir wollen jetzt zu unrate HTTPS nach unrate port 1443 websocket
support weiß ich nicht ob wir es brauchen aber wir machen es einfach mal rein ssl zertifikat
das da force ssl auch gut hat tp2 support why not so und von der idee her sollte ich
jetzt so auf mein unrate kommen und ein gültiges zertifikat haben und ich bin auf meinem unrate
haben ein gültiges zertifikat nice ja das funktioniert bin begeistert dann ist das doch
ziemlich easy dann klappt das so wie ich mir das im vorfeld überlegt habe dann klappt
das so so und dann testen dann testen wir noch mal ein paar andere sachen also so man
der englische nx proxy manager allein bringt jetzt ja auch nichts wir machen mal einen
who am i container oder sowas doku wiki doku wiki ist so easy das klappt immer doki wiki
install nein nicht vom previous previews port 43 nein doch aber hier auf custom proxy und
wir wollen keine ports weiter leiten als doku wiki weil warum wollen wir keine ports weiter
leiten als doku wiki weil wir wollen dass das über diesen reverse proxy geht also brauchen
wir keine ports weiter leiten vom host sondern wir müssen auf den reverse proxien von da
auf das doku wiki also es müsste eigentlich so passen custom-netzwerk proxy ansonsten
können wir alles die ford lassen apply jedenfalls ist es dann gestartet wenn ich glück habe
ja es läuft gut keine ports weitergeleitet ist ja auch logisch wollen wir ja auch nicht
und jetzt können wir das hier einrichten host proxy host add proxy host ja wie nennen wir
das denn doku wiki da müssen wir jetzt übrigens gleich einen host eintrag erstellen weil
das nicht in meinem dns drin steht wobei ich kann es einfach in mein dns eintragen doku
wiki punkt htp vor geworden auf doku wiki jetzt können wir uns ein feature zunutze machen
was docker intern wie das docker intern handelt wenn zwei docker container am gleichen interface
hängen dann kann man innerhalb dieses netzwerks den container namen quasi wie als würde
im dns server stehen ansprechen also ich heiße ich kann jetzt einfach sagen ich möchte
hier proxy auf doku wiki und das checkt er dann auch auch doku wiki websockets wahrscheinlich
nicht so doku wiki links custom location ssl mein wildcard zertifikat htp 2 meinetwegen
oder bar so jetzt muss ich also das hier geht noch nicht und hier doku wiki bem warum geht
es nicht weil ich kein dns eintrag habe dass ich mache jetzt in meinem router schnell mal
ein dns eintrag für die kiste und dann sollte es funktionieren dns static add new item
doku wiki punkt und die adresse ist die vom unrate also im prinzip ok kann man es ausprobieren
ob funktioniert ping ja pink und jetzt sollten wir eigentlich auch direkt drauf kommen und
wir haben ein gültiges zertifikat kein forst ssl näher anderweitig komme ich eh nicht
drauf also eigentlich kann man setzen nicht wirklich bringt jetzt glaube ich an der stelle
nicht wirklich was weil man hat eh keine möglichkeit anders drauf zu connecten als
über den proxy proxy ja nur nur ssl drüber yo also das funktioniert wie verschlüsselt
man am einfachsten seinen datei ordner bevor man sich die cloud storage hoch lädt also
ich finde er klauen eigentlich ganz gut für sowas aber ich muss sagen ich habe mich da
selbst noch nicht mit rum bekleckert ich mache aktuell kein offsite backup das steht seit
jahren schon so auf meiner agenda aber ich habe es noch nie auf die reihe bekommen wieder
was sinnvolles auszudenken aber er klauen ist glaube ich ganz gut von dem was ich so
gelesen habe das unterstützt also dass da github unterstützt mehr oder weniger alle
cloud provider die es so gibt du kannst auch hetsa die hetsa storage box nehmen genau kann
das ding hier hetsa das steht aber glaube ich nicht drin aber die haben glaube ich
noch mehr wie kein hetsa support oh ja du kannst aber auch tatsächlich in hetsa storage box
nehmen ausrufe zeichen hetsa im chat für einen 20 euro start an der geht ja gar nicht
mehr der ist letztes jahr abgelaufen die müssten echt mal zu portal kommen hier
und da kannst du per ssh drauf und dementsprechend kannst du da mehr oder
weniger alles machen kannst von web darf bis erst hinkt bork back ab alles mögliche
samba kannst du sogar mounten und dann ist eh vorbei hetsa billiger als strato für was
also für einen teil virtualisierten low budget vm server wahrscheinlich nicht weil da gibt
zwar strato ein für ein euro aber das ist crap das ding root server also viel wager
kann es jetzt ja nicht sein was also du musst schon gucken was du brauchst also ich meine so
pauschal kann man das nicht sagen ist es eher storage lastig cpu lastig was brauchst du an
ressourcen wie brauchst ja mit traffic inklusive traffic nicht inklusive send traffic receive
traffic inklusive da musst du vergleichen das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen ich ganz ehrlich
ich glaube unterm strich wird sich wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viel nehmen wobei ich denke dass du
bei hetsa eher das angebot findest was du suchst weil die einfach mehr auswahl haben was so was
angeht aber da musst du gucken das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen ja so also jetzt haben
den docker container wir können unseren kram zertifikaten die einzige sache die ich mir jetzt noch die ich mich
jetzt noch frage ist wie kriege ich ein gültiges zertifikat von dem engine x proxy manager
auf mein android drauf das gültiges zertifikat hat wenn ich nicht über den reverse proxy
g also ich weiß wo es hin muss es muss auf den usb stick drauf aber wie kriege ich das aus dem
container raus wie wo ist das denn gemontet warte mal wo ist das denn gemontet
mnt user so ab data glaube ich sind die container engine x proxy manager
das encrypt ja genau live und da müsste eigentlich müsste es da jetzt für die alle
zertifikate npm 1 ok da ist es wahrscheinlich drinne ja hier das war ein private key für das
zertifikat theoretisch müsste ich den kram jetzt einfach auf den usb stick kopieren das müsste
funktionieren guckt mal settings ich glaube management access ist das hier guckt mal ich
habe das ja schon mal drauf kopiert in letzten kript zertifikat aber ich will ja dass es
automatisch automatisch dahin kommt die letzten kript zertifikate also zertifikate für für
android selber muss man glaube ich kopieren nach boot configs ne boah keine ahnung ssl
vielleicht ich habe es ja schon mal hinkopiert also ja genau android bundle pimp so muss es
heißen also ich müsste damit das funktioniert
ne
geht auch eine verknüpfung du hast recht ich könnte auch ein symlink machen ja ja
wahrscheinlich ein symlink geht nicht weil beim starten vom android sind die platten noch
nicht gemontet ich muss das kopieren der usb stick ist beim starten auch schon da ansonsten
symlink was ein scheißwort gehen aber so nicht
wie kriege ich denn das jetzt darüber da müssen wir mal google befragen ich habe da irgendwas
gefunden android engine x proxy manager copy
wohin nach boot configs man könnte das mit einem userskript machen oder man könnte den
userskript machen was einfach einmal in der nacht des zertifikat kopierten engine x neu
startet habe ich sowas erst habe ich sowas schon mal ausprobiert warte mal boot config
plugins userskript ne scripts ne
wie kriege ich das zertifikat jetzt einmal in der nacht rüber kopiert
vor allem was muss ich denn überhaupt rüber kopieren
ja ja was muss ich hier rüber kopieren ist die sache ich gehe nämlich mal von aus dass
der private key wird nicht alleine wird es nicht wird es nicht sein
ich bin ich bilde mir ein ich muss glaube ich glaube ich muss
pull chain und private key rüber kopieren oder zert und private key zert und private
key muss rüber kopieren aneinander aneinander gehängt
wenn ich das wenn ich das richtig in erinnerung habe
ich weiß es aber nicht mehr genau hier hier hier hier hier da da die anleitung hat ich
glaube ich gesehen hier copy
Grill full chain bundle
Zertifikatsgebastel da Adding Zertificats
Haste das hier gesehen?
Genau, man muss den Server Key und man muss das Server Zertifikat und den Private Key
zusammenhängen und dann hier speichern irgendwie drunter Server Zertifika also das da und das da
muss ich speichern nach Boot Config SSL Zerts unter dem Namen. So und wenn das funktioniert,
das testen wir jetzt mal und wenn das funktioniert dann sollte der mir normalerweise
jetzt hier unter Manage Access gleich ein neues Zertifikat anzeigen. Also merken wir uns mal,
das aktuelle Zertifikat was ich habe läuft am 18. Mai aus, das heißt wenn das jetzt funktioniert
sollte ich ein neues Zertifikat bekommen. Also, machen wir das mal mit absoluten Faden,
weil brauche ich das später im Skript auch. NPM, warum NPM? Das erinnert mich irgendwie an so
JavaScript-Gedöns. NPM live, das Zertifikat zeige ich euch den Inhalt jetzt aber nicht,
cool. So, das Zert kann ich euch zeigen, aber den Private Key soll ich euch nicht zeigen.
Private Key PEM und jetzt das ganze nach Boot Config SSL, SSL Zerts Unrate Bundle. So, ist
das jetzt richtig, was ich hier mache? Ich hoffe mal. Gut und jetzt habe ich jetzt hier
ein neues Zertifikat. Hey, guck mal, easy, hat funktioniert. Das ist alles was ich ausführen
muss, einfach einmal nachts oder so. Ich kopiere, weil Let's Encrypt erneut glaube ich ja eh 10
Tage bevor es ausläuft, das heißt ich kann diesen ganzen Schmodder hier nehmen. Dann brauche ich
User Scripts, wo habe ich User Scripts? Installed App, User Scripts, Settings, so neue Script,
Enter Name for Script, ja genau, Copy, Unrate Zert oder so. Unrate Zert, ok. Ok, jetzt muss ich
nach Boot Config Plugins Scripts. Du könntest auch das Verzeichnis vom Stick in den Docker
mounten und dort direkt die Zerts hin erstellen lassen. Lass mal überlegen ob das sinnvoll ist.
Nee, ist nicht sinnvoll, oder? Doch, das könnte man machen. Das müsste gehen. Nee, könnte ich
nicht, weil die Zertifikate, die müssen aneinander gehängt werden. Ich muss auf jeden Fall ein
Script ausführen. Also da kann ich es auch gleich kopieren und dann saut mir der Docker nicht auf
den USB Stick rum. So, Script, Chat. Chat habt ihr aufgepasst, habe ich den Webserver neu gestartet
oder nicht? Ich glaube nicht, ne? Ich glaube kopieren reicht, Webserver neu starten muss
nicht sein. Obbei es schadet auch, es schadet ja auch nichts den Webserver neu zu starten danach.
Schadet ja, wie startet man? Braucht es nicht? Aber reloaden sollte ich den Engine X schon,
dass der neues Zertifikat lädt. Jaja, reloaden muss ich den auf jeden Fall. Wie macht man das
System? CTL? Nee. Oh Gott, wie startet man Sachen? Ist das noch old school? ETC in a D? Nee. CLI,
Android, Restart, Service. Was? ETC, RCD? Okay, das ist Slackware, wir sind noch richtig old school. ECD? Ist doch ein Engine X, oder? Ja. Haben die sowas wie Reload?
Nice. Dann will ich das hier auf jeden Fall in dem Script noch drin haben. So. Ja, das Muster auf
jeden Fall noch rein. Sicher ist sicher. Und das wars jetzt soweit. Fertig. Und das lasse ich jetzt
einmal. Beakly reicht. Daily reicht, ist ja egal. Laufen. Das war es eigentlich, das müsste funktionieren.
Und jetzt bekomme ich auch, bevor ich mein Array gestartet habe, ein gültiges Zertifikat hier auf
dem anderen Port. So, nice, das funktioniert. Das ist tatsächlich einfacher als gedacht. Ich
weiß, wenn man so abgedrehte Dinger macht, die bei Android nicht direkt vorgesehen haben, dann
ist es ja nicht schlimm, dass man hier so ein Customs Skript für braucht. So, was könnte man
jetzt noch ausprobieren? Leute, was sind denn Apps oder Community Plugins, die man unbedingt
haben sollte und die man unbedingt ausprobieren sollte? Gibt es da noch irgendwas? Ich meine,
VM muss ich jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht installieren. Unassigned Devices. Nee, Virus-Scan brauche ich
nicht. Unassigned Devices. Nee, brauche ich nicht, weil ich habe keine unassigned Devices.
Piehole-Docker-Container brauche ich nicht. Da habe ich anderweitig schon was laufen in der
Richtung. Das habe ich nicht da drauf. Libre-Speed. Okay, Libre-Speed sehe ich den Sinn ehrlich gesagt
nicht, warum ich mir selbst ein Libre-Speed hosten sollte. Nee, mir geht es jetzt um irgendwelche
Plugins. Uptime-Kuma habe ich auch anderweitig. Ach nee, das bräuchte ich tatsächlich da wieder
drauf. Aber das sind ja nur irgendwelche x-beliebigen Docker-Container. Das ist jetzt ja egal. Also,
ich sage mal, geht hier ein Docker-Container, gehen sie alle. Home Assistant und Outlet. Ja,
das brauche ich auch. Das mache ich aber als VM. Ich habe doch hier ein Video mit meinem Zeug
drin. Lib wird Hotplug-USB. Ach, das geht standardmäßig nicht, oder was? Ich kann
standardmäßig nicht in einer VM USB-Sticks rein rausziehen, aber dann brauche ich das.
Also, es macht keinen Sinn, warum sollte ich hier mal ein Git gedönnt, warum sollte ich
ein Home Assistant und dann den Kram hier noch installieren. Das sind Docker-Container wie alles
andere. Auch wobei ein Home Assistant das Thumbnail, ja. Da habe ich mir lange überlegt zu.
Ich glaube, wir installieren mal eine VM. Wir installieren eine Home Assistant VM,
aber nicht, um sie jetzt irgendwie großartig zu konfigurieren, sondern mal um zu schauen,
wie das mit USB-Path pass-through ist. Wo habe ich denn meinen Konbi-Stick? Der ist immer gut
zum Ausprobieren, ob er funktioniert. Konbi-Stick, wo bist du, Konbi-Stick? Da ist der Konbi-Stick.
Exzellenter Konbi-Stick. So, das testen wir jetzt. Home Assistant VMWR, da brauchen wir das Image
von Home Assistant. Wir wollen es installieren auf VMWR. Es gibt mittlerweile so viele Sachen
zum Downloaden. What the fuck? Wo ist es denn? Ist das jetzt blöd? Hat das hier nicht sonst?
Ach hier, da ist es doch. Nee, nicht Community. Wo ist das denn? Da stand VM in Klammern.
Warum Home Assistant als VM und nicht als Container? Weil Container-Installationen immer weniger
supportet werden. Es gab früher die Möglichkeit, dass du diese super weiße Container-Installation
machst, dass du quasi das, was Home Assistant OS auch machst, auf einem selbst installierten
Server machst, aber das wird immer schlechter supportet und immer nur noch unter ganz merkwürdigen
Rahmenbedingungen, wie das dann Netzwerk-Config muss beispielsweise über Home Assistant gemacht
werden, nicht mehr über das House OS und so was. Und dadurch, dass die ganzen Add-ons
nicht funktionieren, wenn du das als Docker-Container laufen lässt, lasse ich es als VM laufen.
Weil die Add-ons sind teilweise wirklich praktisch. Da hast du dann irgendwelche fertig konfigurierten
Dinger, was weiß ich, für einen fertig vorkonfigurierten MQTT-Server oder du hast irgendwelche Home
Assistant Custom-Script-Geschichten als Add-on. Also du kannst bei einem normalen in Docker
installierten Home Assistant keine Add-ons installieren. So, das finde ich doof. So,
Home Assistant Operating System VM. Okay, VM. Virtual Box, da sind wir doch. Vor allem
der Workstation KVM, wir wollen KVM. KVM wollen wir haben. Und zwar, wo ist das Image?
Sag mal, vielleicht soll ich mal meine Schrifte bisschen kleiner stellen, dass man was sieht.
Download Image, KVM, QQ. Die Q ist wieder am Start. Okay, MNT, cache, wobei wir machen
jetzt einfach hier User, Mains, Biget. Oder laden wir mal das Image runter. Ja, das können
wir jetzt nämlich auch gleich mal mit einer VM ausprobieren. So, was wollen wir haben?
Minimum 2 GB, das kriegen wir hin. 32 GB Storage kriegen wir auch hin. Mindestens 2 CPUs kriegen
wir auch hin. Also, was will der haben? Generic Default Network UEFI, Linux, Type. Was will
der von mir? Click Add Hardware and select Channel, select Device Type, Unix, select
Name, Org, QEMO Guest Agent. Warum brauche ich einen QEMO Guest Agent? Ach, wahrscheinlich
dass die Uhrzeit und sowas dann auch alles stimmt. Okay, ich habe keinen Wirt Manager.
Ich habe nur dieses komische Ding hier. Schauen wir mal, ob es so funktioniert. Add. Ist der
Download fertig? Ja. Linux, Name, Home Assistant, CPU, drei Stück. Weil wir machen hier keine
halben Sachen, kriegt drei CPUs und gut ist. 4G. OVM ist gut. USB Controller sollte auch
reichen. Primary Disc Location. Die liegt Manual, User, Domains. Habe ich doch gerade hinkopiert.
Ah, ich muss es noch entpacken. Ich muss noch entpacken. Oh Gott, wie entpackt man den XZ?
Können die das nicht in irgendeinem normalen Kompressionsformat machen? UnXZ. Kommst du
dir vor wie 1965? Entpacke mal. Oh Mann. Bald Mittagsschlaf, Leute. Da ist doch Kuckau.
Recycle Bin für Shares, Tipps und Tricks. Oh, das ist gut dahin und das kopiere ich mir
mal raus. Da haben wir gleich schon mal einen Look drauf. Fixed Common Problems. Das ist
ein Addon, das klingt erst mal vom Namen her schon nicht schlecht. Domains. Da ist es
doch. HAOS. VIRTUAL BUS. Da stand noch was von SATA, oder? Also WIRT-AO. VNC. Nein,
Rich 0 soll das Ganze. USB Device is available. Gibt's nicht. Ne, machen wir dann danach.
Gut. Ja, schauen wir mal. Create. Gucken wir mal, ob das jetzt funktioniert. Was? MonkaS,
Alter. Popperplocker. VNC Remote. Da sind wir. Ja, und schon startet mein Home Assistant.
Das ist nice. Das ist wirklich easy. Forever Guest Agent. Es gab noch einen Addon für
den Wirt Manager. Das habe ich gesehen. Es gab noch einen Wirt Manager. Ja. 2021 und
der ist von 2017. Ne, dann nehmen wir lieber den da. Vielleicht brauchen wir da. Ich glaube,
das Wirt Manager Addon zu installieren ist gar nicht so schlecht, weil falls man doch
mal irgendwelche Custom Sachen machen muss vielleicht. Okay, ich habe einen Home Assistant
laufen auf. 1 und 2, 1, 6, 8. 2.50. Ist es nicht 3128? Doch. 8. Ne, 8123. Okay, da sind
wir. Nice. Install. Web UI Port 8135. Scheiß drauf, braucht kein Mensch. So, und jetzt
können wir nämlich... Und jetzt können wir mal gucken, ob Hotplug mit dem USB funktioniert.
Da bin ich jetzt nämlich echt mal gespannt. So, Admin, Passwort 123456. 123456, yes.
Ja, ja, Amsterdam, alles gut. Time Zone. Matrix System, ja. Keine Freedom Units hier,
please. Next, Finish. Sehr schön. So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob Hotplug funktioniert.
Also sprich, wenn ich einen USB-Stick anstecke, ob er den dann auch in der VM erkennt. Da
bin ich gespannt drauf. Dazu brauchen wir erstmal den SSH Addon für den Home Assistant,
dass ich da was sehe. Advanced Mode, yes. Gibt es Alternativen zum Home Assistant? Ja,
es gibt jede Menge Sachen, die in die ähnliche Richtung gehen. Also du hast Open Hub ist
wohl noch das zweitbekannteste da vorne. Dann hast du Sachen wie IO Broker, die auch relativ
bekannt sind. Femme ist in Deutschland recht beliebt. Wobei, ganz ehrlich, guckt euch mal
das UI an. Das will man, glaube ich, nicht haben. Aber hey, ich meine, es funktioniert,
ja. IO Broker ist noch relativ beliebt. IO Broker ist noch relativ beliebt. Open Hub
ist noch relativ beliebt. Aber ich glaube, insgesamt muss man echt sagen, Home Assistant
ist wahrscheinlich aktuell das verbreitetste. Ich denke, auch die meisten Sachen findest
du für Home Assistant. Und eins muss man Home Assistant mal gut anrechnen. Die haben
eine schöne Oberfläche und eine Oberfläche, die auch gut customizable ist. Ich könnte
mir vorstellen, dass du vielleicht manche Nischen-Dinger beim IO Broker besser angesteuert
bekommst, aber dann kannst du immer noch den IO Broker irgendwie von Home Assistant einbinden,
wenn es unbedingt sein muss. Das sieht wirklich aus wie mit Frontpage erstellt. Ja, ist echt
so. Supervisor Addon Store. Wir wollen ein SSH Addon haben. Install. Jetzt gucken wir
mal, ob der die USB-Sticks und sowas erkennt. Ham is in Perl geschrieben. Oh Gott. Ich dachte,
es kann nicht mehr schlimmer werden, nachdem ich die UI gesehen habe. Aber nee, jetzt ist
es komplett vorbei. Configuration. So, Passwort. Qt, Chat, Save. Start. Hat's funktioniert?
Okay. SSH, Hass, IO, Add, dem da. Qt, Chat. So, also, wir haben kein USB aktuell erkannt.
LS-USB. Bam. Ach so, ja, das ist natürlich doof jetzt, weil es... Nee, nee, kein USB.
Das ist kein Container. Vergiss, was ich gesagt habe. Okay, also, gab es nicht LS-USB-T für
Tree oder sowas? Also, es gibt keine USB-Geräte. Das sind die Controller. Da ist kein USB-Gerät
dran. So, jetzt testen wir mal, wie das funktioniert. Wie kriege ich in Unraid an die VM ein USB-Gerät?
Also, ich hab hier mein Konbi-1-Stick. Den brauch ich nicht, weil eigentlich hab ich
den Konbi-2. So, Konbi-Stick ist drinne. Wir sehen den Konbi-Stick jetzt wahrscheinlich
auch hier auf Anpa-Unraid. Da, guck. Hier ist der Konbi-Stick. LS-USB. Ich vermute mal,
das hier ist der Konbi-Stick. Oder was auch immer. Das hier. Nee, hier haben wir es doch.
Das hier ist der Konbi-Stick. Future Technologies. Das hier ist der Konbi-Stick. So, und wenn
ich hier drinnen guck, LS-USB ist noch nix da. Jetzt heißt, wie kriege ich das USB an
die VM? Ach, da ist er noch. Guck mal da. Leben wird Hot Plug in USB. Hab ich schon gesehen,
aber mal gucken, ob das einfach so funktioniert. Nee, doch. Oder? Es ist jetzt mehr. Aber da
sollte mir eigentlich was ordentliches anzeigen. Was ist das nochmal? DEV? USB? Nee. USB by
Bus. Bus ist es, ne? Nee. Ach man, wo ist das Scheiß nochmal? By ID. Linux, Proc, USB by ID.
Nee. DEV-USB by ID gibt nicht. Pseudo-LS-USB? Hä? Nee, oder? Nee, nee, das bringt in dem
Fall gar nix. Äh, war das? Nee, nee, nee, das war doch was anderes, oder? Org-Bus-USB?
Wo ist denn dieser Kram nochmal? Sys-Bus. Was? Sys? Nee. Ach, DEV-Serial meine ich.
Ja, genau. Ich suche nicht USB. Du hast recht. Ich suche DEV-Serial. By ID. Da ist er doch.
Da ist er doch. Und wozu brauche ich jetzt das Hot Plug? Es funktioniert aber auch so?
Oder was funktioniert mit dem Hot Plug jetzt besser? Das ist er doch. Wozu braucht man
jetzt das Hot Plug plugin? Muss mal kurz gucken, was sie da zu schreiben. Hot Block. Jetzt mal
ziehen und wieder stecken. Ja, das kann man probieren. Okay, was macht das? Runnig, allows
mounting USB-Devices on running VMs. Ja, haben wir doch eben auch gemacht. Apps. Ähm. Nee,
lockerer Container. Ich bin für VMs. Da. Edit. Und jetzt wieder weg. Update. Aha. Okay,
das funktioniert nicht. Bell to attach device from. Bam. F. Dafür brauchen wir wahrscheinlich
das Plugin, dass das ordentlich funktioniert. Hä? Und wenn ich das wieder attache? Nope.
Okay, dann probieren wir das jetzt mal mit dem Plugin aus. Da muss ich aber wahrscheinlich
einmal. Ja, ist halbwegs neu. Wie verwendet man das Addon jetzt? Ah, hier unten. Ah. Attach.
Attach successfully. Ja gut. Und jetzt? Detach. Ah, nice plugin. Sehr gutes plugin. Okay,
das finde ich gut. Poggers. Das finde ich gut. Das ist auch schön im UI hier drinnen.
Dann findet man das wenigstens. Ah, dann kann man den Müll hier unten einfach in Ruhe
lassen. Ja. Wir machen mal kurz die VM stoppen. Bekommst oben im Header-Menü auch ein USB-Tab.
Oh. High IQ Shit hier. Nee. Bekomme ich nicht. Fake News. Ich bekomme kein USB-Tab. So,
dann nehmen wir jetzt mal die VM. Gucken dann noch mal in die Settings rein. Okay, ist es
nicht. Es ist nicht attached. Sagen wir jetzt Start. So, und jetzt kann man den Kram an
und abstöpseln darüber. Das finde ich ist ein wirklich sehr gutes, sinnvolles Plugin.
Das brauche ich. Weil gerade bei meiner Home Assistant Geschichte möchte ich ja schon
mal vielleicht irgendein USB-Gerät an und abstöpseln. Und sei es nur, dass ich irgendwie
der Container für Zigbee2MQTT verschluckt hat und ich den Stick mal ziehen muss oder
so. Das finde ich sehr gut, dass das dabei ist. Das gefällt mir gut. Das hat sich schon
mal wieder gelohnt. Hat sich schon mal wieder gelohnt den Chat zu fragen. Chat ist einfach
wie immer Next Level High IQ. Five Head Chat, ja. Ja, Nix drinnen. Okay. Und jetzt Running
VMs. Also muss ich mal kurz neu starten. HA Attach. Bäm und die Weiße ist da und Bäm
und die Weiße ist weg. Sehr gut, sehr nice. Das finde ich gut. Das gefällt mir. Exzellent,
exzellent. Exquisite sozusagen. Zeit ist richtig. Pock. Gut, jetzt hat irgendjemand noch ein
paar andere Addons vorgeschlagen, die ich mir angucken soll. Und zwar, ich soll mir
ein Recycle Bin für Shares, Tips and Tweaks zum Beispiel, Nick Buffer Size. Ach nee,
das ist eins. Das ist eins. Fixed Common Problems, CA Backup Restore. Nice, serious. Weil es
fällt, ist wirklich Pock. Ich werde aber demnächst mal wieder ein bisschen was mit View machen,
denn ich habe halt das Gefühl, es ist immer noch so, dass du für View einfach mehr Support
drum herum findest. Also mehr Libraries und mehr Tutorials und mehr Hilfen und alles.
Weil es Welt halt wirklich Five Head ist. Also dann probieren wir nochmal was anderes
aus. Also Apps. Ach so, wir müssen unsere Home Assistant vor allem ja noch beibringen
über a Docker, über Engine X erreichbar zu sein, über den Reverse Proxy. Aber das
ist immer ein bisschen Pain's Champ, das in Home Assistant einzurichten. Das mache ich
zum Schluss vielleicht. Jetzt probiere ich erst nochmal die anderen Addons aus. Also
was? Recycle Bin für Shares. Erinnere mich so an Windows Papierkorb. This plugin adds
per share Recycle Bin Folder to hold Samba Deleted Files until you empty. Ne, das brauchen
wir nicht. Ah, or removed Aged Files on a schedule. Das finde ich gut. Das heißt, wenn
man aus Versehen was löscht auf dem Samba Share, dann bleibt es da drinnen und dann
kann man einstellen, was man sich einmal in der Woche aufräumen oder so. Das ist cool,
das ist nice, das ist gut, das ist gut, das gefällt mir. Das testen wir jetzt gleich mal.
Wir haben ja unsere ISO, unser ISO Ordner mit ein bisschen Zeugs drinnen. Alter Corona,
trinken. Richtig. Ja, trinken. So, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice,
nice. Settings. Enable. Yes. Was Updates Size in Background. Übrigens, das ist auch
eine Sache, die ich ganz nice finde bei Unraid und den meisten Addons, dass die immer so
eine Erklärung dazu haben, was die Einzeloptionen machen. Das vermisse ich bei vielen Programmen,
dass die einfach mal erklären, was manche Sachen, was sich dahinter verbirgt. Die Krönung
ist ja irgendwelche Kommandozeilen Tools, wo du dann guckst in die Manpage oder in Help
und da steht dann sowas drinnen wie keine Ahnung. Minus Q und dann steht dann so sinngemäß
da It's the minus Q Option oder sowas, wo du dann immer denkst, ah ja, ok, wunderbar,
gut, dass ich das jetzt gelesen habe. Übrigens, meine Lieblingsmanpage Intro ist immer noch
für Mann Git Push. Lest euch den Satz durch und dann erklärt mir, was Git Push macht.
Also, Git Push macht Updates, Updates, Remote Refs, Using Local Refs, While Sending Objects
Necessary to Complete the Given Refs. Jetzt ist alles klar, oder? Ich glaube, jetzt versteht
jeder, was Git Push macht, nachdem er diesen Intro-Satz gelesen hat. Also, wirklich. Cringe,
der ist jetzt nicht weiß. Enabled on Unassigned Device Snow habe ich gerade installiert. Removed
Aged Files on Schedule. Was, Notification, was? Achso, nee. Weekly ist wahrscheinlich
sinnig. Ok, Apply. Share. Sollte da nicht was stehen jetzt? Ok, also wenn ich es jetzt
richtig verstehe, wenn ich es jetzt richtig verstehe, gehe ich hier mal ein ISOs-Verzeichnis
und ich lösche jetzt alles. Yes. So, ich lösche jetzt irgendwie 3000 Null-Byte-Dateien
und dann sehe ich die da. Da können wir auch gleich schon mal testen, ob das UI was taugnet,
sich abkackt mit 3000. Funktioniert nicht. She baited. Vielleicht funktioniert das nicht
für die Default Shares, kann das sein? Exclude Shares. Wurde der Samba neu gestartet? Nee,
muss er? Muss er neu gestartet werden? Stand das irgendwo? Refresh unter, ich hab doch
hier alles schon Refresh gedrückt. Da ist nichts. Locks? Ja, meinetwegen, Apply.
Ich sehe hier nichts. Aber, wenn wir den Samba neu starten müssen, machen wir das. Restart?
Das ist jetzt auch gleich den Samba neu. Okay, checken wir das mal. Neues Textdokument,
KekWee. Und jetzt verbreiten wir natürlich einfach mal die reine Wahrheit. Null-W-Größer-KekWee.
Und löschen das jetzt. Yes. Da ist es. Was genau sollen hier in Shares stehen eigentlich?
So. Und wie Restore ich das File jetzt wieder? Wie Restore ich das File jetzt? Es müsste
eigentlich hier stehen, oder? Kann es sein, dass es auf dem ISO Share einfach nicht funktioniert?
Wir machen einfach mal einen neuen Share. Vielleicht funktioniert das auf dem Share
einfach nicht. Keine Ahnung. Der KekWee-Share. Share Name, KekWee. Jawoll. Use Cache Pools
A jetzt unbedingt. Cache. Jaja, alles gut. Und wo stelle ich jetzt das Verzeichnis ein?
Moment, ich bin, ich checke es an. Ach, das legt er für mich an. Ich muss das gar nicht
selbst anlegen, ne? Add Share. Done. Apps, install apps. Äh, wie ist das? Isos. Jetzt
hat er es gecheckt, oder wie? Warum hat er denn so lange dafür gebraucht, bis er das
kapiert oder was gelöscht hat? Okay, Browse. Hier, KekWee TXT. Da ist es doch. Aber es
gibt, es gibt keinen Button zum, äh, zum Restore an der Stelle. Das heißt, ich muss
dann sagen wir mal hier. Ach hier. Ah, guck mal hier. Hier gibt es einen, einen Recycled
Ordner, wo das jetzt drin ist. Alles klar. Okay, okay. Das erscheint mir aber doch wirklich
ein nützliches Plugin zu sein. Das, das erscheint mir tatsächlich echt, das ist nicht schlecht.
So, was soll ich sonst noch ausprobieren? Tips and Tweaks hat jemand geschrieben. Tips
and Tweaks. Das ist eine Samba-Standardfunktion. Ja, aber anscheinend kann man es nicht darüber
konfigurieren. Wahrscheinlich wird das Addon auch nichts anderes machen, wie irgendein
neues, ein kleines Snippet in der Samba-Conf hinzufügen. So, Tips. Tips and Tweaks. Hallo?
Oh, das ist für die Hacker-Mans hier. Richtiges Hacker-Man-Addon. Done. Actions, Settings.
Boah. Erstmal volle Pulle. Ja, alles klar. Nick Flow-Control. Nein, warum soll ich das
disablen? Warum soll ich an meiner Buffer-Size irgendwas rumdrehen? Ja, gut, vielleicht um
irgendwas zu optimieren und auch ein paar Bites rauszuholen. Obwohl ich mir nicht vorstellen
kann, dass man da viel, also wirklich substanziell, groß was optimieren kann. Was? Disk? Cache?
I-Notify-Gedöns-CPU-Governor-Power-Safe. Ja, okay, das ist so was. Wenn man es braucht,
dann braucht man es, aber ansonsten braucht man es wahrscheinlich nicht. Ich meine, das
trifft doch fast alles zu, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine. Wenn man was einstellen will,
weiß man, dass man es braucht, ansonsten kann man es sich schenken. So, was haben wir noch?
Fixed Common Problems soll ich noch installieren. Weil? Weil Common Problems gefixt werden.
Okay. Das haben wir doch schon mal ausprobiert, oder? Okay, wir fixen Common Problems. Easy.
Easy as f**k. Wenn man so einfach immer Common Problems fixen könnte. Ich werde gescannt.
What? Was will es von mir? Okay, aber was? Center-Diff?
Wird doch da nirgendswo? Bright Cache ist Disabled, warum?
Ah, ähm, das ist sich aus Sicherheitsgründen wahrscheinlich deaktiviert. Falls der Server
crash noch was im Cache ist oder sowas, gehe ich mal von aus, dass sie deswegen sowas reingehauen
haben. Your cache drive is SSD Drive, but you do not have was Dynamics SSD Trim Plugin
installed. Wie, das Ding, das Ding trimmt meine SSD nicht automatisch, da brauch ich
ein Plugin für? Hätte ich jetzt eigentlich gedacht, dass es das tut. Trim Plugin. Warum
trimmen die meine Cache SSD nicht automatisch? Das ist aber schwach. SSD Trim Install. Und
wer stellt jetzt sicher, dass die Addons nach jedem Update noch funktionieren? Ich meine,
wenn ich mein System jetzt mit 30 Addons vollklatsche, dann mache ich ein Update von Android 6.9
auf Android 6.10 und die ganzen Addons gehen nicht mehr. Ich weiß, es hat mir im Chat
schon mal jemand geschrieben, die wäre dann angeblich relativ pingelig, aber ich glaube
es erst, wenn ich sehe. Ok Trim. Trim. SSD Trim Settings. Trim. Naja hourly ist vielleicht
weekly. Weekly reicht. Sonntag 0 Uhr. Ja Trimme Sonntag 0 Uhr. Gib ihm. So was haben wir
sonst noch zum ausprobieren. Backup. Backup und Restore. Was? So. Das da. Und warum? Weil
man die VMS und die Container backupen kann. Das ist tatsächlich sinnvoll. Ja. Da hätte
ich mir jetzt normalerweise irgendeinen R-Sync dafür gebastelt. Ja, aber das ist tatsächlich
ganz sinnig, wenn das das machen kann. Ohne dass ich es selbst machen muss. Ja, das finde
ich eine gute Idee. When a backup is running. Was? Your docker application will be stopped
and then restarted. Ok, das geht nicht anders. Du kannst du kannst die Sachen nicht konsistent
backupen, während sie laufen. Das stimmt schon. Man könnte. Man könnte sein. Cash
auch einfach auf btrfs machen und Snapshots machen. Wobei das es auch nicht konsistenter
macht, weil wenn Daten packen, was im Ram haben oder so ist, es geht ja wahrscheinlich
schneller. Was ist denn heute los? USB Backup ist deprecated. Android Version. Nein, ich
will nicht das Android Dotnet Plugin. Ich brauchte. Ich will doch kein Cloud Geschiss haben, um
mein App, um mein Zeug zu backupen. Das soll alles schon offline funktionieren. Der Cash
ist nicht btrfs bei mir. Nee. Use compression. Hab genug Platz. Appdata Backup, Mount User
Community Backup. Source. Aja. User Appdata. Oder mein.
Huge. Huge TLBFS. USB Backup Destination. Ah, das ist jetzt für. Ok, das muss ich mir
in Ruhe mal angucken. Das ist jetzt nichts, was man mal kurz auf die Schnelle bastelt.
Ich verstehe. Aber das scheint mir auch recht praktisch zu sein. Nee, aber ich muss sagen,
ich finde das äußerst nice, wie gut das funktioniert mit dem Container Management hier drüber.
Da kann man sich doch echt nicht beschweren. Du startest neue Kiste, legst eine Name in
deinem. Deinem DNS an. Fügst es beim Proxy Manager hinzu und schon hast neuen Container
ein gülliges Zertifikat. Das ist doch wirklich. Also viel einfacher kann es eigentlich nicht
funktionieren. Ach ja, wir müssen mal testen, wie das beim Neustart ist, ob der Kram sich
dann auch alles neu startet. Was braucht das System jetzt eigentlich? Das ist gerade unfair
zu gucken, weil alle Platten hochgefahren sind. Es ist alle Platten und CPU Last drauf,
aber ich kann es dir sagen, wenn du es willst. Also ich kann also Eidl. Eidl verbraucht das
System. Mit 10 Gigabyte Netzwerkkarte drin braucht das 20 Watt. Jetzt mit drei aktiven
10 Terabyte Festplatten und aktiver CPU sind wir bei 62 Watt. Also wenn ich die Platten
runter fahre, sind wir wahrscheinlich bei 30 oder so. Also wenn die, ich kann ja mal
gucken, wir machen Share. Nein, ich kann jetzt nicht ausschalten, weil ich die ganzen Docker
Container oben habe. Okay, Sekunde. Stopp. Stopp. Stopp. Wobei ich muss es gar nicht
von Hand stoppen, oder? Das macht ja noch alles automatisch. So Rebuild. Pause Champ
und Stopp. So und dann Spin. Ach nee, ich noob. Jetzt kann ich nicht Spin Down machen,
wenn ich es gestoppt habe. Ich hätte es nicht stoppen sollen. Ich hätte es einfach nur,
naja. Nur warten, bis es gestoppt ist. Jetzt sind wir übrigens schon bei 49 Watt. Einfach
nur durch keine CPU Last. Pause Champ. Pause. Pause. Champ. Champ. Champ. Ach, V-Logs,
von dir habe ich das doch, oder? Hast du mir das das letzte Mal nicht auch empfohlen,
dass ich mir das kaufen soll? Dieses QNAP-Ding? Ich habe das jetzt drinne. Ich habe das eingebaut.
Weiß nicht, ob du am Anfang da warst. Guck mal, ich habe das jetzt drinne. Guck mal. Es
ist gleiche bis sie schneller. Ich meine nicht, dass es großartig was bringt. Ich meine, warum
brauche ich eine SSD, die 2,3 Gigabyte die Sekunde schreibt, während ich über das Netzwerk
maximal 10 Gigabyte drüber kriege. Aber das macht ja nichts. Und wie warm? Ja, maximal
70 Grad die SSD. Also das Raid ist nicht das schnellste im Stoppen. Leute, ich muss upgraden.
Also, ich meine, überlegt mal. Ich habe jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder ich sage, okay,
die Geschwindigkeit von der SSD ist jetzt halt verschenkt und 10 Gigabit reichen mir,
oder ich sage, ich muss unbedingt auf 40 Gigabit Netzwerk bei mir upgraden, damit ich meine
SSD ordentlich ausnutzen kann. Ich glaube, es wird Zeit für 40 Gigabit daheim. Nein,
wird es nicht. Schwachsinn, mach ich nicht. Das ist absolut nicht wert. Aber ich meine,
man könnte, man könnte, ja. Aber nee, kann ich nicht, weil ich habe ja keinen PC-Express-Slot
mehr frei. Sag mal, was ist denn hier los? Warum stoppt, choppt, stoppt, champt das Ding
nicht? Wahrscheinlich, weil ich in MNT-Cache drinne bin. Das hat er nicht gecheckt, dass
ich in MNT-Cache drinne bin. Jetzt, jetzt hat er es gecheckt. Aber ich bin blöd. Also
jetzt braucht er 49 Watt. Ich muss es nochmal starten, dass ich es dann spinndownen kann.
Ja, cringe, wer keine 100G daheim hat. Ist so, ja. Wie heißen die Dinge eigentlich? Also,
ich weiß, bei 10G hast du SFP-Plus-Module, bei 40G hast du QSFP-Module oder sowas in
der Richtung. Kennst du dir einer von euch mit aus? Und was hast du bei 100G? Wie heißen
die Digger dann? Frostchamp. So, Pause und jetzt mach ich, pass auf, spinndown. Spinndown.
So, die Platten sind alle aus und die Platten sind noch nicht aus. Die Platten klicken
jetzt und jetzt haben wir 33 Watt. Ganz ehrlich, Leute. 33 Watt für drei Platten, die Karte
drin, die SSD. Wobei was hat, jetzt hat doch eben auch einer im Chat geschrieben, was es
braucht. Guck mal. Ich habe bei einem Microserver 4, 6TB, Platten 2. Ja gut, wenn alles an ist,
wenn es power down ist oder spinndown ist, brauchst du natürlich weniger. Aber 33 ist
doch absolut in Ordnung. Ich meine, da sind drei Festplatten drin. Eine 10G-Karte und
eine NVMe-SSD. Da kannst du nicht, also normalerweise sind es 20, das heißt durch der ganzen Shit,
der drinnen ist, kommen jetzt noch mal 15, sagen wir mal, drauf. Das ist okay. Du hast
keinen spinndown eingestellt. Ja, ich habe jetzt ja absichtlich mal gesagt, spinndown,
was ich jetzt sehe. Ja, das ist echt in Ordnung. Ich meine, von der Idee her, ich müsste hier
auch nicht dreimal 10TB reinpacken. Ich könnte auch einfach zweimal 16 oder so reinpacken.
Aber warum sollte ich, ich meine, ich habe die Dinger hier noch, warum sollte ich die
wegschmeißen? Ich meine, wozu? Nice, nice, nice. Ja, ich muss sagen, das gefällt mir
eigentlich ganz gut jetzt. Hat was. QSFP28 nennt sich das. QSFP28. Ach ja, nice. Hat
Mikrotik 40G-Switche. 40. Da hier, jawoll. Bäm. Kost. Ja, geht doch, geht doch. Geht
doch, geht doch. 180 Euro oder sowas. Zwei QQ Plus Module. QSFP Plus Ports. Was kosten
so Netzwerkkarten? Das ist wahrscheinlich deutlich teurer, oder? Gibt es dafür Direct
Attach Kabel, Leute? Ist das hier, gibt es dafür Direct Attach? Die sind immer relativ
billig. Ja, hier. Nice. 30 Euro. Leute, ich sehe schon kommen, bald ist 40 Gigabyte angesagt.
Weil es geht, weil es geht. Ja, ich brauche noch eine Netzwerkkarte. Wo guckt man da am
besten auf Ebay nach irgendwelchen ausrangierten Dingern? Geht doch, geht doch. 80 Euro für
eine Netzwerkkarte. Also ganz ehrlich, ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass man mit, sagen
wir mal, 3 bis 400 Euro dabei ist, was 40 Gigabit angeht. Ich meine, du brauchst zwei
Netzwerkkarten vorneweg. Du brauchst zwei Direct Attach Kabel und du brauchst den Switch.
Gut, du brauchst den Switch. Du kannst natürlich die Dinge auch miteinander verbinden, aber
ich gehe jetzt mal nur ein bisschen mit schönerem Setup aus. Das ist doch echt in Ordnung.
Nicht, dass man 40 Gigabit daheim jetzt wirklich brauchen würde. Ich meine, es ist schon fragwürdig,
ob man 10 Gigabit wirklich braucht, aber es ist auf jeden Fall cool zu haben. 2,5 definitiv.
Also, ich versuche es mal anders zu sagen. Also ein Gigabit Netzwerk daheim ist okay,
aber gerade wenn man halbwegs geschwindes Nass hat und da öfters auch was mitmacht,
zum Beispiel, dass man Gameplay Sachen drauf kopiert oder es gibt ja auch Leute, die machen
da drüber Videoschnitt oder sowas, dann muss es mehr sein als ein Gigabit, weil sonst ist
das nervig. 2,5 Gigabit ist da schon deutlich besser, weil 2,5 Gigabit kannst du ziemlich
exakt über den gleichen Kram machen, den du schon liegen hast daheim. Du kannst auch
10 Gigabit höchstwahrscheinlich über den Kram machen, den du daheim liegen hast, aber
2,5 Gigabit geht definitiv und 2,5 Gigabit ist relativ günstig. Da gibt es USB Netzwerkkarten
für ein Apfel und ein Ei und Konsumer, so 0-5-TP-Link-Switches und sowas können das
teilweise auch schon. 5G ist auch ähnlich, ja, da sind aber die Netzwerkarten ein bisschen
teurer und dann würde ich gleich einfach schon 10G nehmen. Also ich finde 5G hat so wirklich
hat, 5G finde ich hat nicht so wirklich die Daseinsberechtigung. Weil du findest kaum
5G-Switche, die nicht auch 10G können. Und ansonsten kannst du auch gleich 10G nehmen.
Genau, weil viele Mainboards auch 2,5G-Ports drauf haben, 5G-Ports eher nicht. Also 5G
weiß ich nicht, ob man das wirklich braucht, ja. Dann kann man auch einfach gleich ein
10G-Interface nehmen. Aber 2,5 ist wirklich für jeden sinnvoll. Also ich denke 2022 ist
das eigentlich das, wonach man gucken sollte. Weil die meisten rennen noch mit einem Gigabit
daheim rum, das reicht ja für die meisten auch, aber sobald man mal ein bisschen was
größeres überträgt, ist das, also lokal ist das dann schon spürbar, der Unterschied.
Und es ist wirklich schon spürbar, ob man 125MB die Sekunde überträgt oder irgendwie
300. 350, was ist denn? 350 oder sowas? Ja, wir können es einfach ausrechnen, 2MB, null.
Gigabit, Gigabit, Gigabit. Ja, 312. Oder ist doch teurer, habe ich mich verguckt? Hat
ich eben danach gesucht, da hat irgendwie 180 gekostet? Oh, wie komme ich nur vor 180?
Habe ich eben nicht 180 gesagt? Wie, warum ist das jetzt so viel mehr? Ok, dann ist mir
ein 400 Euro doch nicht dabei. Lulve. Ja, dann nicht. Falls sich mal jemand fragt, 1G
gleich SFP, 10G SFP plus, 25G SFP. Meinst du, das kann ich mir jetzt merken, falls mich
mal jemand fragt? Das lese ich mir jetzt durch und dann habe ich wieder vergessen. 25G SFP
28. Ich meine, die Benamung wäre ja vielleicht, also warum heißt es eigentlich nicht SFP
plus plus und das SFP plus plus plus? Oder meinetwegen, warum nicht SFP plus zwei, SFP
plus drei? Ich meine, man hätte die Dinger doch irgendwie sinniger benennen können als,
ich meine, warum 28, wenn es 25 ist? Und ich meine, QSFP DD 800, das werde ich mir im Leben
nicht merken können. Wisst ihr was? Man hätte die Dinger auch sinnvoll benennen können.
Man hätte die zum Beispiel auch, meine SFP war schon da, lass ich mir gefallen. SFP plus
war auch schon da. Warum nennt man den ja nicht zum Beispiel SFP 25 und den SFP 40 und
den SFP 100? Dann könnte man sich ja direkt was unter dem Namen vorstellen. Das hat mit
der Anzahl der Data Lanes zu tun. Ja, ich meine, das mag technisch die Begründung sein, das
ist übrigens auch die Begründung, warum USB 3.2 gen dreimal zwei heißt oder so. Versteht
aber kein Mensch. Also, die mit WiFi 6 machen das richtig. Einfach sprechen benennen irgendwie.
Ja, ich bin auch dafür, wir sollten das SFP gen 3.2 gen 2.2 zweimal zwei revision 2 nennen,
dass man Bescheid weiß. Außer kräftig, ja. Was WiFi 6 revision 2 gibt es das wirklich?
Oh Mann, und ich hab die immer so schön gelobt, dass es einfach ist durchzublicken bei WiFi
6 mittlerweile. Das ist vorbei. Jetzt musst du immer gucken, ist es WiFi 6? Moment, ist
es vielleicht WiFi 6 release 2? Das ist richtig dumm. Richtig dumm. PR Abteilung gefeuert.
Oh Mann. Na ja, egal. Also Leute, schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid. Ich mach mich jetzt
vom Acker, geh jetzt mal aufs Klo, es drückt und wir sind fertig mit ausprobieren. Ich
weiß nicht, was ich sonst noch ausprobieren soll. Ppupupu mach ich jetzt. Fangen wir jetzt
mit HDMI. Oh, nee, nee, nee. Bloß hören wir bloß mit HDMI auf. Wobei bei Displayport
das ja auch undurchsichtig hoch 3. Okay, wir sehen uns. Bis dann, machts gut. See you.